[Musique]
bon allez on travaille plus
vos bombes à
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle l'émission qui ne dort
pas avec nous ce soir à la madeleine
laurent bastille
elisabeth teissier omar raddad luis
fernandez d'eugène saccomano airy
routier
saskia mulder basile boli mélanie doutey
doc gynéco et philippe starck et notre
fameux light est consacré ce soir à la
pop music à lanester
[Musique]
je vous propose maintenant de regarder
les meilleurs moments de l'émission dont
tout le monde parle
ça s'appelle toulon la barre l'est et
s'est préparé par jean yves noël
[Musique]
magnéto serge je vous propose de tourner
aujourd'hui votre séparation comme ça on
leur a parlé pendant lés prises sur
caméra café
bon bah ouais non mais il ya un moment
je suis possible que les gens qui ont
toujours besoin d'être rassurés admirer
encensé c'est fatigant quoi je sais pas
un moment c'est moi si ça qu'ils vont
embêter chez lui c'est ce côté
ces difficultés qu'il a à faire des
phrases simples par exemple une fois si
vous lui parlez encore
tu es encore là mais je dirais va dormir
avec ta chemise de blaireau est ce que
est ce que les facteurs c'est comme les
plombiers est-ce que des fois quand on
apporte le courrier il ya une dame comme
ça car en nuisette on rentre et puis
tout est possible il ya que ça qui vous
intéressent est ce que pour vous je suis
un antisémite je vous pose la question
écoutez je vous ai vu participer à des
tas de manifestations dans lesquelles on
traitait les juifs de nazis et ça c'est
un fait des propos diffamatoires vous le
savez le consistoire le sait toutes les
organisations de la communauté via
diallo bon et j'espère un défaut
j'espère du fond du coeur moi j'ai vu la
communauté juive arrêtera se faire
représenter par des gens comme vous ça
passe pas il ya des insultes qui passe
pas ouais ils se retrouvaient la sphère
traite à mi-mots d'antisémite
c'est dur en tous les cas ça prouve que
vous avez du coeur que la révolution
c'est aussi une affaire d'amour alors à
faire connaissance qui est à mia talea
il soit vous êtes de sydney est ce que
vous aimez le sexe tania
non parce que vous avez un cooking
comment vous traduisez coquine non non
non légiste c'est too much non tissé
beaucoup ça veut dire la tension est à
traductrice talent
la traductrice exagère beaucoup et alors
vous vous appelez jc sa grille aggir
jamais le sexe autant il avait
directement
alors moi je prends l moi donc c'est
choisi - séguin y en a une gestion vous
êtes très jaloux the c'est aguilera
voulez mais vous l'avez pas j'en étais
sûr qu elle est plutôt vulgaire
bon c'est pas vulgaire c'est ça que
cette formule du temps est ce que les
gars là quand vous appelez gérard
j'appelais bien j'étais fou oui j'irai
sûrement sait ce que ça veut dire
gerhardt guérard fort en javelot avant
lances puissantes lorsque je t'encule
pendant parler de tout ça est ce que
vous êtes content de pouvoir diriger
gérard depardieu dans astérix c'est pas
le mot de diriger est un peu fort on
dirige pas de partie on essaie de le
calmer
que pensez-vous gérard jugnot de
l'évolution des films de gérard krawczyk
de l'été en pente douce jusqu'à taxi
trois de ses films un peu moins
personnel mais bon c'est bien fait leur
avis est ce que vous êtes le vrai gérard
jugnot qu'on me fait envie mais je veux
pas me fâcher avec personne
aucune société digne de ce nom ne peut
pas considérer que la prostitution est
un bien moi je pense qu'elle pourrait
être un bien et même on pourrait être
même manar c'est vrai que les nanas qui
sont là et qui sont cinéastes qui sont
écrivains et qui prennent leur belle
plume pour dire ouais faut laisser les
nanas se prostituent etc
j'y crois pas trop - la réalité du
terrain me paraît tout autre les nakiska
y les meules dans les campings cars
l'habitude avec soient attaquées par des
hordes de voix mais moi j'ai du mal à
croire qu'une nana elle qu'une femme
pardon eh bien elles choisissent d'être
d'être prostituées et et qu'elle
s'éclate dans son boulot et que ces
gosses s'éclate pas ce qu'elle fait ce
métier là et que tout le monde lui
sourit et qu'elle est à l'aise tant sur
les circonstances et je n'y crois pas ça
mais je t'ai je me trompe peut-être
commis les travailleurs je vois pas
quelle est la différence entre le type
qui travaille on est là c'est qu'on vend
stylo qui vend ses mains et un salaire
de misère mais qui ont minimisé qui ne
s'occupent pas ce cas ce que vit sous le
prof deux de ses voisins chevaux quand
vous voyez en effet des gens qui sont au
smic des jeunes filles qui sont au smic
qui elles savent très bien que les
différences parce qu'elles vivent dans
des conditions difficiles mais c'est pas
pour ça qu'elles vont se prostituer
parce qu'elles savent très bien ce qui
est une atteinte à la dignité humaine il
est pas et c'est bizarre que vous
vouliez vous voyez pas et maintenant
j'accueille
[Applaudissements]
vous connaissez marcela le spectacle de
michael non à la fois le voir moi je ne
connais pas non plus vos recherches donc
j'ai pas tellement on pourra en discuter
après
tu feras un bout de mon spectacle et
vous ferez des recherches je met tout le
monde d'accord
j'ai un truc du peu de calme et c'est
fait la charge
[Musique]
c'est que tu veux pas toujours les
gabarits vifs
voilà c'était tout le monde a parlé et
s'est préparé par monsieur jean lionel
messieux
[Applaudissements]
m
j'accueille maintenant alain madelin
[Musique]
et
alors un bon soir bonsoir
donc vous êtes député ump
d'ille-et-vilaine ancien ministre merci
d'être là parce qu'on a longtemps
cherché avec catherine barma quelqu'un
un homme politique qui soit favorable à
la position américaine donc à la guerre
en irak
franchement c'est pas facile puisque je
crois qu'il ya jamais eu une telle
unanimité dans le pays puisque le peuple
français dans son ensemble vous l'avez
lu dans les sondages rejette cette
guerre voilà et vous vous êtes pour
est-ce que c'est pas une posture pour
vous singulariser merci de m'accueillir
comme une sorte de minorités opprimées à
laquelle vous de ce fait la parole dans
cette émission c'est ce qui fait son
charme
ouais mais côté il peut arriver par
moments que l'on puisse à avoir une
opinion différente après tout c'est pas
plus mal et que sur le long terme on
s'aperçoit qu'on n'avait pas tort et je
me souviens il ya quelques années
j'étais de ceux qui disaient les
démocraties doivent aider le commandant
massoud
ouais à débarrasser l'afghanistan du
régime des talibans eh ben je prêchais
bien seul finalement on avait raison oui
alors vous êtes pour la guerre même sens
l'onu vous vous dites la position qui
consisterait le cas échéant à se passer
de l'onu serait légitime
notre place est aux côtés de l'amérique
les 17 résolutions de l'onu qui à ce
jour n'ont pas été respectées par saddam
hussein lui donne le droit aux états
membres d'intervenir le cas échéant pour
faire respecter ce droit
ce n'est pas une dictature comme les
tout comme toutes les autres parce que
lui il a perdu une guerre il en est
résulté des obligations internationales
deux obligations internationales la
première respecter les droits humains
sur le sol irakien
ce n'est pas respectée la seconde
désarmés ce n'est pas respectée donc on
va faire la guerre à tous les gens qui
respectent pas les droits de l'homme
dans leur pays il ya du boulot hein
le nombre - mais ce n'est pas parce que
vous ne pouvez pas arrêter tous les
criminels que lorsqu'il ya un criminel
en bas de chez vous vous n'allez pas
l'arrêter alors vous dites donc le cas
échéant on pourrait se passer de l'onu
ça serait légitime jeudi que les
résolutions du conseil de sécurité
j'ai même apporté avec moi la résolution
14 141 du conseil de sécurité
rappelons que dans ses résolutions le
conseil de sécurité a autorisé les états
membres à user de tous les moyens
nécessaires pour faire respecter et
appliquer la résolution
je dis simplement qu'on n'a pas besoin
de nouvelle résolution du conseil de
sécurité que les 17 résolutions
antérieures suffisent cela étant je suis
partisan de la position française qui a
consisté à essayer de faire en sorte que
le conseil de sécurité puisse avoir un
nouveau délibérer
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça moi je
souhaite que la france soit aux côtés
des américains oui oui dit notre place
est aux côtés de l'amérique dont vous
avez la même position en fait que kas
narc tony blair que berlusconi
d'ailleurs vous étiez au courant donc
vous étiez au courant
la déclaration qu'ils ont fait dans le
journal protesté du côté américain avant
l'elysée et matignon
ben écoutez si l'on appelait la question
n'est pas savoir si j'étais au courant
la question ne pourra être posée à
l'elysée à matignon pourquoi veut il
n'était pas le grand nous avait prévenu
les américains n'ont pas du tout bon ça
c'est un secret de polichinelle je crois
oui alors est-ce que vous pensez que
dans les semaines qui viennent jacques
chirac va utiliser son droit de veto le
droit de veto de la france au conseil de
sécurité ou bien il va laisser faire la
guerre sans y participer vraiment où il
va retourner sa veste
trois solutions la france sera en tout
cas c'est ce que j'espère aux côtés des
états unis
pourquoi parce que manifestement saddam
hussein n'a toujours pas rempli ses
obligations fallait à l'heure actuelle
on est un peu victime d'une illusion
d'optique parce qu'on voit les
inspecteurs puis on y voit une sorte de
partie de cache-cache on ira cosy
maitien faut que les inspecteurs y
trouve ce n'est pas vrai la résolution
de l'onu elle ne dit pas ça la
résolution de l'onu n'impose pas aux
inspecteurs de trouver elle impose à
saddam hussein de montrer de montrer
qu'il a désarmé ce qui n'a manifestement
pas fait mais les aspects si on a rien à
montrer non mesdames le bénéfice du
doute que sous les gueules mec monde
quelque chose il a rien à montrer
vous pourriez avoir raison sauf que vous
devriez lire le rapport de hans blix non
le premier rapport là qui vient de
déposer et qui lui aussi est accablant
il dit lorsque nous avons quitté l'irak
en 1998 il y avait tout ceci il y avait
de l'anthrax il y avait du bacille de
charbon
il y avait du gaz vx il y avait des
milliers de tonnes de chimiques
fait des détonateurs d'armes nucléaires
ou s'est passé à la banque d'avoir
besoin dans le blick pour dire ça
puisque c'est les américains qui lui ont
vendu non saddam hussein tous et tous
ces armes chimiques de toute façon non
ce n'est pas ceci n'est pas exact mais
c'était christine et orange qui n'a pas
été démentie jeu toute une série de pays
dont la france ont aider l'irak à
s'équiper de l'armé nucléaire dans un
autre contexte même ce que j'ai regretté
moi même à cette époque
toujours est il que saddam hussein a
aujourd'hui le depuis 12 ans
l'obligation de désarmer qu'il prouve
qu'il a désherbé il aurait fait quoi de
gaulle
je crois que de gaulle non tout décider
dans toutes les circonstances de ce
style était aux côtés des américains
pensaient que de vols auraient fait la
guerre à saddam hussein ce qui est en
cause c'est de faire d'obtenir du régime
de saddam hussein qu'il respecte ses
obligations et le cas échéant de
renverser le régime de saddam hussein et
renverser le régime de saddam hussein
c'est libérer le peuple irakien vous
savez dans quelques semaines ou dans
quelques mois on aura des images d'un
peuple irakien qui se libèrent des
images de joie qui mangent des
chewing-gums et l'on n'est pas milan et
l'on aura et l'on aura des témoignages
et l'on aura des témoignages sur
l'atrocité de ce régime et sur le
camouflage de ces armes terribles
alors si vous pensez que l'on fait des
guerres pour des mcdonald's
il faudrait que vous m'expliquer que
l'on a été à kaboul pour faire des mcdo
et fonctionnant à plein à josé bové
non mais vous parlez de kaboul on nous
montrait à l'époque des des montagnes en
afghanistan qui étaient des montagnes à
l'intérieur il y avait des caches sont
bien aménagés avec des ascenseurs des
portes blindées enfin brice a toute la
journée la télévision quand les mecs
sont arrivés là bas c'était des grottes
puis c'est tout vous pensez qu'on va
trouver sous l'irak des installations
parfaitement organisés avec des
laboratoires qui préparent des armes
chimiques et tout ça mais cela s'est
déjà produit un après 1991 l'irak disait
que nous n'avons pas d'armes
bactériologiques et puis le gendre de
saddam hussein est parti il a dit aux
inspecteurs si vous allez là là et là
vous allez trouver
les inspecteurs ont été sidérés de
trouver tous les laboratoires
clandestins qu'ils ont trouvé oui c'est
ce qui se reproduira sans nul doute
alors pourquoi les américains disent pas
la vérité pourquoi ils disent que c'est
pour apporter la démocratie en irak ce
dont ils se foutent complètement entre
nous on est bien d'accord parce que
s'ils voulaient apporter la démocratie
il devrait commencer alors la porte et
en amérique du sud c'est plus près de
chez eux mais est-ce que c'est pas pour
garder le contrôle des sources
d'approvisionnement énergétique pourquoi
ils disent pas pour ils disent pas dans
30 ans il y aura plus de pétrole
vous serez bien content qu'on est chopé
l'irak en 2003 parce que maintenant
grâce à nous il ya du pétrole
pourquoi ils disent pas sa place est
dans la vérité parce que c'est pas tout
à fait exact parce que le pétrole c'est
un marché mondial est une source de plus
une sauce en moins ça ne change pas
grand-chose éventuellement ça peut
affecter les prix et si le prix du
pétrole baisse
si l'intérêt de tout le monde mais les
premiers qui sont touchés ce sont les
pétroliers texans bouche tout ce n'est
pas l'intérêt de ce n'est pas l'intérêt
alors il n'y a pas de pétrole en corée
il n'y a pas de pétrole au pakistan par
exemple est ce que c'est pour ça que les
états unis n'attaque pas ces pays là il
n'y a pas de pétrole au kosovo il n'y
avait pas de pétrole au kosovo non et
pourtant les américains sont intervenus
sur le sol européen pour arrêter le bain
de sang du que ce voyage et ils sont
intervenus au profit de qui au profit
d'une minorité musulmane
cette libération est cette intervention
américaine et de la tam
elle s'est faite à l'époque parce que
les choses étaient bloqués au conseil de
sécurité
elle s'est fait sans l'aval du conseil
de sécurité est ce que vous pensez
alain madelin que les américains sont
capables de maîtriser les conséquences
d'une guerre en irak
d'abord la déstabilisation de la zone
parce que ça va pas se faire sans sans
risque au niveau local disons et
deuxièmement est ce qu'ils sont capables
de maîtriser la multiplication des
attentats en europe
j'espère que la guerre sera courte
la libération sera rapide que ceux ci
aura valeur d'exemple et que l'on pourra
créer un nouvel équilibre avec un peu
plus de liberté dans la région quant aux
attentats
j'en sais rien mais si l'on doit
renoncer ici ou là à faire respecter le
droit parce qu'on a peur des attentats
terroristes
or les théories sont déjà gagné ouais
mais alors si on vous suit là après
l'irak qui vont s'attaquer à l'arabie
saoudite parce que l'arabie saoudite et
encore moins de liberté et de droits de
l'homme en irak les racks un pays laïc
l'arabie séoudite on vous coupe la main
quand vous volez on lapide les femmes
adultères donc on ne peut imaginer
qu'ils vont attaquer l'arabie saoudite
après premièrement s'agissant de l'irak
je vous invite à lire le rapport de la
ligue internationale des droits de
l'homme
c'est vraiment un des pires régimes qui
soit 500 mille kurdes exterminer 4
millions en exil 182 mille disparus
franchement c'est un régime abominable
je dis pas ça pour excuser l'arabie
saoudite parce que j'en pense pic et
pendre mais simplement je dis que l'irak
est hors la loi hors la loi
internationale et que là on a le droit
et le pouvoir d'intervenir
je pense j'espère que ceci va servir
d'exemple et qu'au lieu d'avoir cette
sorte de statu quo des dictatures c'est
pas bon pour la paix c'est pas bon pour
les peuples dans la région eh bien on va
avoir une évolution de tous ces régimes
je l'espère vivement bien sûr aussi pour
l'arabie saoudite s'est sérieusement que
tous ces pays vont devenir des
démocraties parlementaires avec une
gauche et une droite et voilà je pense
que ça viendra je pense à un exemple
très simple en irak vous savez il ya
déjà le kurdistan au nord qui est libéré
ballet au kurdistan vous verrez c'est un
peu une suisse est un peu de la
démocratie
alors il ya une autre issue c'est que
les américains ne gagne pas la guerre et
qu'il la perde pas qu'est ce qui se
passe dans ces cas là vous voulez dire
quoi qu'il ne la petite nature qu comme
ça s'est passé en afghanistan comme ça
s'est passé au vietnam cirque en
afghanistan si l'on me karzaï à kaboul
ils tiennent pas le blesle et au vietnam
ils ont été obligés de partir donc ça
aussi c'est une hypothèse qu'on n'est
pas comparable ige d'envisager pour ma
part j'étais partisan depuis longtemps
d'aider les forces du commandant massoud
ce qui aurait peut-être été une
meilleure façon de le saison on ne l'a
pas fait et je le regrette c'est vrai je
le regrette mais s'agissant de de l'irak
je pense que la guerre devrait être si
guerre il ya à moi que je l'espère
peut-être que saddam son fût avant mais
si hier ici guerre et il devait y avoir
elles seraient rapides sans trop de
dommage tant dommage pour les
populations civiles que
vraisemblablement on aurai je l'espère
en tout cas une sorte de révolte interne
qui chasserait que saddam et très
rapidement la paix alors ensuite il
faudra reconstruire votre conseiller est
ce que vous êtes en train de dire est ce
que vous regrettez c'est que les
américains soient pas assez rester en
afghanistan donc vous
invité à leur demander de rester un peu
plus longtemps en irak quand je pense
pas que les américains puissent
contrôler l'afghanistan personnel bien
sûr que non jamais personne est arrivé
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous aurez
très rapidement un régime irakien irak
aux irakiens qui se mettra en place et
qui je l'espère débouchera le plus
rapidement possible sur des élections
libres
oui parce qu'on a tendance il met un
général américain à bagdad il y aura des
soucis mais vous avez une opposition
irakienne elle existe même si elle est
capable de se mettre d'accord n'existe
pas aujourd'hui personne par challe où
10 personnes ces pièces et lcl se
réunira sur le sol irakien je peux le
dire le 15 février prochain
à bord c'est bien me connaissez c'est
vrai que cette histoire bouzid europe
puisqu'il ya une ligne madelin blair
aznar berlusconi 1 puis après de l'autre
côté il ya la ligne fraudeurs chirac
et puis les pays de l'est qui voulait
rentrer dans l'europe et qui montrent en
fait que ils sont pas capables de
rentrer dans l'europe puisqu'ils sont
tous alignés sur les états unis tout de
suite non est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
venu à l'idée que les pays de l'est
avaient été victimes pendant des
décennies d'un régime totalitaire et
d'une terrible oppression et que
l'europe qu'ils souhaitent c'est une
europe qui défendent les libertés dans
le monde
c'est pas un alignement sur les
etats-unis c'est tout simplement des
gens qu'il sorte de l'oppression qui ont
envie de donner la liberté aux autres le
monde d'être américain a sorti de ça
c'est quand même la première fois qu'un
seul pays veut dominer et diriger le
monde sait jamais arrivé jusque là
y'avait l'urss oui et maintenant ça y
est la fille aux quais si vous pensez
que les américains sont trop forts et
que vous n'avez pas qui décide tout seul
ce qu'on appelle l'unilatéralisme
américain fait l'europe fait le
multilatéralisme démocratique
essayons de faire grimper l'europe et
puis entendons-nous avec les américains
pour décider ensemble
bien sûr cela nous écouterons comme
j'écoute blair contre par un peu le
caniche les américains êtes d'accord
mais pourquoi voir cette caricature
permanente des etats unis avait il ya à
l'heure actuelle des partout dans le
monde et dit dizaines des centaines de
millions de gens qui sont opprimés par
des dictatures qui souffrent de la
misère et qui regarde vers les
etats-unis comme une terre de liberté
qui aimeraient y rentrer et qui vous
rentrez en irak les américains c'est
tout
bien non sérieusement est-ce qu'on n'est
pas dans un processus de colonisation il
ya tous les éléments de l'accusation et
la mission civilisatrice
car on y va au nom des droits de l'homme
on y va pour rétablir la liberté c'est
ce qu'on dit tous les colonisateurs
quand ils sont allés occuper les pays
d'afrique et d'asie à l'époque il ya
plus de 100 ans
et puis l'intérêt économique aussi en
même temps d'appliquer un peu de pétrole
et puis on perdra moins cher donc on est
dans une vraie phase de colonisation
sont des clichés
les américains nous ont délivré d'un
totalitarisme afro le nazisme
c'était pour nous coloniser pour
organiser la même si aujourd'hui nous
sommes en liberté nous le devons aux
sacrifices des américains et si ensuite
face à la menace que représente l union
soviétique
nous avons gardé notre liberté c'est
parce que les américains ont risqué une
apocalypse nucléaire pour nous protéger
oui mais à l'époque à l'époque de cuba
quand les russes envoyer des armes à
fidel castro on les voyait sur les
bateaux là des gens les voient pas sur
les bateaux les armes malgré tout les
satellites qu'ils ont mis et puis
ensuite c'est parce que les américains
nous ont libérés en 45 qu'ils ont raison
pendant toutes les cabines ont bien sûr
mais cela veut dire qu'en tout cas vous
pouvez pas leur faire un procès
d'intention
et s'il faut choisir entre à qui je suis
le plus confiance ouais saddam ou bouche
la démocratie américaine où le régime
irakien
pour moi c'est la démocratie américaine
où et excuse est pour la peine de mort à
la madelin plutôt non ça veut dire que
quand même dans certains cas ça veut
dire que je me pose très sincèrement en
conscience très sincèrement en
conscience le la question pour eux un
certain nombre de crimes abominables
dont on peut penser qu'ils ont fait
quitter la nature d'êtres humains à ceux
qui les commettent
oui je me pose cette question est ce que
vous êtes pour la peine de mort pour des
enfants innocents dont le seul tort est
de vivre chez saddam hussein voulu dire
quoi la couverture jette des bombes de
10 mille mètres d'altitude ça peut
tomber sur des gosses
[Musique]
oui bien sûr oui bien sûr eh ben ça j'en
veux pas mais dans le même temps il faut
mettre ça en balance avec qu'est ce qui
se passe si le régime de saddam hussein
continue avec la misère l'oppression les
tortures rien de bien finir par mourir
il ya un mec qui les mettra un coup
c'est juste une position mais c'était la
mienne
longue vie aux dictateurs ils finiront
bien par passer oui mais en attendant
gaver pinochet oui mais en attendant un
le malheur des peuples
vous n'êtes pas sensibles vous tout à
fait sensible j'essaye merci à la
et maintenant
[Musique]
facile en avi
ben voilà alors laurent je voulais te
faire un cadeau pour fêter ton retour
dans cette émission j'ai hésité entre
elizabeth teissier geneviève de fontenay
pourquoi t'as pas choisi une vieille
plus tôt et finalement j'ai choisi
elizabeth teissier pour
elisabeth et ses bons soirs alors
lisabeth tout fout l'camp vous quittez
télé 7 jours vous régné en maître depuis
26 ans dans ce journal si on a des
images qui me dit pas non regarder non
dit voilà c'est elisabeth teissier à
télé 7 jours et maintenant donc mais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pourquoi vous
avez à tv magazine qu'est ce qui s'est
passé a débuté ses thèmes les astres
d'abord aborder ces thèmes et zastre
maintenant je vais dans un groupe qui
maquille montreuil avec ac la passion
c'est la nouvelle passion alors qu'on
venait me suis très très content de
rentrer dans un groupe d'avoir trouvé
maintenant un homme aussi beau heureux
et plus riches quand le blé
c'est dans son signe en même temps la
prime lunettes
soit
on allait donne 6 octobre du labrador
efforts n'ont jamais astigmate sur les
bords et auquel isabelle désormais vous
êtes à tv magazine magazine qui est
diffusée chaque semaine par 41 quotidien
'aujourd'hui vallée qui vont à 5
millions d'exemplaires 5 millions deux
parties
ça fait plus de blé sept jours ci d'un
boeuf pour qui bon bah non parce qu'on
est pas payée au tirage ah bon
deux fois sur les rails dans le bouquin
je prévois tout répéter non j'ai pas
parlé de l'irak dans mon bouquin
non par contre sur mon site j'ai parlé
de la guerre longuement en analysant
c'est trop compliqué pour expliquer ici
ben oui bah il faut aller sur mon site
non mais c'est déjà aussi les photos
subir un petit peu la cat et son écoute
bien alors on essaie mais c'est
extrêmement compliqué parce que si vous
voulez ce qui m'interpelle dans tout ça
ça a l'air d'être un peu une tautologie
c'est que c'est la complexité astral de
dans laquelle nous nageons depuis
septembre en vertu d'un cycle jupiter
neptune qui est aussi celui qui fout la
bourse en l'air qui est responsable des
inondations et des problèmes de
pollution jean prestige et tout ça je
quitte jamais oui pas l'affréteur du
bateau qu'il n'y avait rien maintenant
tu es toi parce que tu me déconcentre
bien sûr mais toi aussi tu es me
déconcentre chanter le dos bon alors et
alors et donc je pense que cette pleine
lune étant très très mauvaise aussi par
ailleurs avec toutes sortes d'autres
aspects dont je ne parle pas que de
toute façon malheureusement je crains
d'abord qu'il ya un événement majeur qui
va intervenir dont je peux difficilement
dire la nature un attentat est possible
vu la configuration les insurrections
donc de nouveau de la pollution on est
en plein dedans dont peut-être que c'est
ce sont les effets du prestige prestige
qui vont arriver sur nous j'en sais rien
du lit dans le passé s'est désabonné
mais c'est vrai quand je suis arrivé en
france 14 18 mois
et mignons les minions alors il y aura
des renversements d'alliances au
détriment des usa parce que les usa et
bouge sont très très touché par cette
pleine lune
à tel point je vous ai demandé s'ils
auraient pas un attentat contre enfin là
bas ou contre bush parce que
figurez-vous ce qui est très amusant
entre guillemets c'est que bush et les
etats unis sont le soleil au même
endroit il son cancer tous les deux les
états unis sont dès le 4 juillet et
boucher dès le 6 ils ont le soleil au
même endroit pratiquement et donc ils
sont terriblement touchée par un smicard
et d'uranus ce jour-là pour cette pleine
lune et c'est très explosif donc je me
suis dit en regardant j'ai regardé plus
près le thème de l'irak que j'ai
superposé au thème de soul un dixième
des états unis et saddam hussein je peux
je pense je pense
il est possible qu'ils soient éliminés
en mai de la cellule de la scène
politique
en mai c'est possible parce que il est
dans le
rouleau compresseur là depuis octobre
sur le tout franchement il en est aussi
la dernière pour le mois de mai elles
avaient dit qu'ils auraient du muguet
moi j'écoute
on attend surtout pour faire taire un
peu ton coup dur alors non on continue
elisabeth celle là pourrait en fait
c'est pas série alors j'avais chaud
série weeds à laurent bon dieu de la
guerre dans la guerre la guerre la
guerre elisabeth qu'henri mais justement
donc je pense que il va y avoir un
événement très très très fort parce que
apparemment il est improbable que la
guerre éclate de 16-17 sinon j'aurais
dit s'il ne connaissant pas du tout le
contexte aurait dit elle peut éclater
entre le 16 et le 21 février voilà
maintenant je dis il va y avoir un
événement drastique qui va peut-être
accélérer le processus
donc peut-être un attentat j'en sais
rien et cette guerre pourrait éclater au
moment où il ya un afflux qui touche à
la fois le thème états unis et celui
d'irak à savoir entre le 8 et le 12 mars
d'accord voilà vous donner c'est une
terre bien et visa bête vous êtes
docteur en sociologie vous avez écrit la
situation épistémologique de
l'astrologie à travers l'ambivalence
fascination rejet dont les sociétés
postmodernes puissance avait déchargé
les deux fois et loria un autre bien
bien l'autre sociologue qui s'appelle
patrick peretti watel vous savez ce
qu'il a écrit oui je sais il a fait une
analyse il a étudié dans cet intéressant
il étudie votre oeuvre dans télé 7 jours
et il a publié les résultats dans la
revue française de sociologie écrit à
droite puissante jamais voulu le publier
et alors il dit non mais ce qu'il dit
c'est un vrai méchant ce qu'il dit vous
allez répondre en direct il dit dans
l'horoscope de télé 7 jours
les gens sont rarement sexuée il dit que
c'est souvent des femmes dans un univers
masculin
by la finitude ans associé la bastille
comme vous attendez attendez thierry ce
que répond qu'il a copié ses adorno
adorent nous a fait une critique à 50
ans ge dont je parle dans ma thèse
il ya 50 ans 1953 de chevaux de travail
sur sur le lien non sur la une
un horoscope qu'ils aillent et qu'ils
étaient parus dans le los angeles times
à l'époque le make up yeux à copier sur
lui carrément parce que quand il dit ça
mais ça me fait vraiment sûrs les dream
que je suis une conformiste que je
j'écris au genre dans un esprit
conformiste en leur disant surtout ne
fait pas de vagues
obéissez à votre patron
profil bas et tout c'est le contraire
devant tempéra il divo horoscope pousser
la passivité la soumission à l'ordre
social
la soumission au supérieur et vous
donnez toujours comme conseille de faire
profil bas
vous dites que c'est de rester cool web
soyez zahi les aurions été dans les
ombres sauvage
je suis pas du tout pour les horoscopes
lénifiants et j'allais dire 500 mille
fois je suis pour dire les choses quand
quelque chose quand on est né le 18 on
est né le 18 novembre
tant pis si ça dérange je dis qu'elle
est la manière de la meilleure manière
de vivre les voir un aspect et il ya
toujours une manière de positiver les
choses oui ça c'est ce qui dit il dit
que vous amener les gens à accepter
l'ordre social
il est supérieur il dit non vous allez
pas les genres philadelphie dit que vous
ne venez pas les gens à demander des
augmentations de salaires par exemple
c'est vrai qu'on lira remontée n'est pas
vraiment ce que c'est si avancé quand
c'est bon je dis quand vous avez un bon
jupiter demandé une augmentation avec 80
ce moment pour un second importe quoi
isabelle c'est bon 18 c'est bon pour moi
et 28 degrés
[Musique]
c'est bon ici il ya un très bon saturn
en deux 2 mois trois non non non alors
il dit aussi que vous amenez vos
lecteurs à couper les ponts avec les
amis qui servent à rien voilà que vous
êtes très comme ça très très pragmatique
mais vous les obliger à faire une
sélection dans les relations sociales
elisabeth tissu de calomnie parce que je
moi j'ai une religion de l'amitié alors
c'est vraiment n'importe quoi c'est
n'importe quoi j'ai fait j'ai écrit un
droit de réponse de quinze pages à cette
revue de la sociologie puisque je suis
sociologue annie monde y écrivait on va
le passer au comité de rédaction de
lecture avant de bon j'ai jamais une
nouvelle voilà ce que s'est passé le
dans tv magazine
c'est beaucoup trop ardue un million
d'exemplaires au cou trop parler pour
détourner les magazines dans mais bon
c'est emmerdant
interview astrologie
est ce qu'il vous arrive elizabeth
teissier de lire dans le passé pour
retrouver vos clés non à ce moment là je
fais du pendule d'accord est ce que vous
croyez les années de taissy qu'il va y
avoir un loft story 3 mais j'en ai
aucune y est c'est des questions de
adana pour toi et moi ils sont pour des
voyantes
rien n'est pas dans une cabane dont la
fête foraine à la foire du trône bordel
mais à part la soirée des chanteuses
québécoises la linda lemay de tâches à
saint-pierre et stéphanie boulay est-ce
qu'il va y avoir d'autres attentats à
paris au printemps
je vais défoncer seront plus ces nanas
la demoiselle est bon je les connais à
peine j'aime beaucoup moins mais je les
connais à peine j'ai pas durer mais par
action soit bien alors vous qui êtes si
forte alors on va voir
j'ai pas dit que j'étais on va voir
quelle est la prochaine question
elisabeth concentrez vous sinon vous
n'allez pas répond et vos lecteurs vont
être déçus est ce qu'il vous arrive
d'avoir des flashs sur l'autoroute
dans notre cas c'est rigolo elisabeth
tessier wii présente quand vos amis
essaient de vous faire une surprise
est ce que vous faites laitonnés par
politesse ça peut m'arriver par gentille
voilà ouais pourquoi les excès quoi vous
savez tout non non grâce au ciel je ne
sais pas tout bon alors dernière
question est ce que vous pouvez me dire
isabelle tessier qui sera le prochain
invité de cette émission juste après
vous donc une idée ça déçoit la france
mais c'est arrivé je pars fêter mon truc
là je suis complètement sur les verts il
ya catherine barma qu'il livre pour
aller faire la fête pour la sortie de
votre journal merci mme catherine chez
tous quatre élus une bise je fais une
bassine scorpions lcd [ __ ] les
scorpions jamais
j'accueille maintenant omar raddad
[Musique]
oui
salut soir omar haddad alors le 24 juin
1991 madame marchal été retrouvée morte
poignardée barricadé de l'intérieur dans
la cave de sa villa la chamade à mougins
sur la porte on découvre en lettres de
sang l'inscription omar m'a tuer or vous
le jardinier de madame marchal vous
appelez justement omar vous êtes
inculpés d'homicide volontaire et
condamné à 18 ans de réclusion
partiellement gracié par le président de
république vous sortirez de prison après
sept ans deux mois et huit jours
derrière les barreaux
mais le 20 novembre 2002 la cour de
cassation rejette votre demande en
révision
votre procès déclarant que les nouveaux
éléments présentés par votre défense
permettent pas de douter de votre
culpabilité
d'autre part l'avocat de la famille
marchal maître kiejman déclare je ne
suis pas étonné qu omar raddad soient
convaincus de n'avoir pas tué madame
marchal tant de gens le lui répète avec
complaisance
depuis si longtemps soutenir qu omar
haddad a été condamné et le reste parce
qu'il est marocain relève de la pure
démagogie dixit maître kiejman
voilà la situation marc haddad gracié
mais pas innocenté donc quelque part
toujours coupable alors avec la
collaboration de sylvie lotir on vous
avez écrit un livre qui est publié au
seuil et qui s'appelle pourquoi moi
[Musique]
donc comme un rat date plusieurs livres
ont été publiés sur votre affaire mais
vous vous êtes dit personne ne peut
parler à ma place mieux que moi c'est
vrai pas mieux moi personne croissante
et quelque chose ça alors le matin du 25
juin 1991 vous discutez avec latifa
votre épouse et sa soeur sur le balcon
de chez vous à toulon lorsque vous
remarqué sans vraiment y prêter
attention
des gendarmes en bas de l'immeuble
quelques minutes plus tard ont sonné à
la porte
il est 11h30 la table du déjeuner est
prête et le t-il dit est-ce qu omar
raddad est là et là vous pensez quoi
rien de ce mariage ou par mourir en
échange de taper à la porte mais belle
se relèveraient la porte qu'on peut être
le temps des scores sur un maharaja lela
l'attendait moineau j'ai présenté il m'a
discuter avec nous j'ai dit oui mais
pourquoi c'est resté comme ça pourquoi
pourquoi prix mais non on ne sait pas je
suis belge d'amour voilà donc au poste
les gendarmes vous dise pourquoi tu as
tué madame marchal vous comprenez pas il
vous montre à ce moment là une photo
d'elle couverte de sang et c'est comme
ça en fait que vous apprenez la mort de
madame marchal commencerait après la
mort de ma démarche
ensuite vous détourner les yeux ils vous
obligent à regarder une autre photo
celle de la porte de la cave où est
écrit avec du sang omar m'a tuer
vous savez pas bien lire et écrire le
français mais vous reconnaissez omar
parce que ça c'est votre prénom dont
vous savez l'écrire et vous comprenez à
ce moment là évidemment qu'on vous
accuse du meurtre de madame marchal
qu'est ce qui se passe dans votre tête à
ce moment là qu'est ce qui se passe
comme ça qu'on va jouer parce que déjà
chez nous au maroc est ce qu on est mort
on crée pas
on bouge pas on mange pas et chez vous
alors évidemment dans les
interrogatoires qui vont suivre vous
êtes victime d'un gros handicap c'est
que vous connaissez mal le français
1 - bien que maintenant évidemment ce
qui permettait dites-vous aux gendarmes
d'écrire à peu près ce qu'il voulait
dans l'est dans les procès verbaux et
vous raconter dans votre bouquin que
quand vous parler arabe
le gendarme continue à taper à la
machine parce qu'à cette époque là il ya
de yahia des questions je comprends il
ya beaucoup de questions je ne comprends
pas c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé
interprète gendarmerie me refuse il m'a
dit on ne connaît votre perdre et parle
bien le français ça que mon père ça fait
quarante lots en france ouais ça fait
commander chacun à sa place mon père
c'est mon père moi c'est moi alors fait
une confiance aveugle aux gendarmes pour
vous les gendarmes ils peuvent pas
mentir donc cette époque là oui oui
vraiment donné oui j'en ai une grande
confiance c'est vrai jamais j'ai pensé à
ma caisse que les passagers retrouver
alors durant toutes ces interrogatoires
vous n'avez pas mais vous dites que vous
finissez par comprendre pourquoi on peut
avouer
parce que finalement on finit par se
dénoncer de crimes qu'on n'a pas commis
simplement pour pouvoir dormir manger et
est allé en paix est là et là vous
comprenez ce qui s'est passé avec
patrick dils finésiens après après parce
que je sais en a beaucoup des gens
posent la question de la taille était ce
pour quoi elle reconnaît un crime n'est
pas fait pour moi je pose pas cette
question
oui parce que j'ai passés par là
n'importe qu'elle est capable d'ouvrir
n'importe quoi même des choses départ
était capable de dire oui tu y signer
tout comme sa tête de la paix parce que
tu es et stéphane tu es fatigué n'était
pas dormir est capable de
de raconter n'importe quoi comme cette
télé star la cause
vous êtes condamné donc à 18 ans vous
ferez comme je les dix sept en huit mois
et 2 jours derrière les barreaux
et vous dites quelqu'un qui est enfermé
pour rien dans une cellule de 9 mètres
carrés ne compte pas les jours mais les
seconds
ouais ouais parce que c'est là c'est la
raison pour laquelle le titre de mon
livre pourquoi moi mais parce que c'est
c'est le seule phrase gdg passe beaucoup
dans ma tête et les de ma tête
pourquoi moi pourquoi je suis là qu'est
ce que j'ai fait c'est ça fait on pose
beaucoup de questions et c'est vrai
c'est pas on n'est pas les journées
passent pas si les sécurités pas se
passer c'est quelque chose
tirer aujourd'hui vous travaillez à
marseille vous prenez le train pour
aller tous les matins marseille à cette
heure de toulon dans une charcuterie
halal dans votre combat maintenant omar
haddad et c'est la raison pour laquelle
vous avez écrit ce livre avec sylvie le
tir on vous voulez que votre innocence
soit reconnue et vous dites si j'étais
coupable
croyez vous que je voudrais un autre
procès oui parce qu'il ya quelque chose
moi je comprends pas son à cause sans
preuve
il est désolé on est tous coupables qui
est tu es mal à marcher à l'omaha d'elle
qu'elle tire de marcheuses quoi cette
question et des milliers de personnes et
pour cette question qui était ma
démarche
malheureusement moi mes avocats
la presse ne sont pas droit d'arrêter le
coupable sauf la justice est notre
moteur arrêté le coupable
quand vous savez dans la phrase de ces
marqueurs omar m'a tuer il ya des traces
génétiques toutes les zones différentes
on a trouvé dans l'eau ça aussi marqué
omar m'a tuer j'ai précise quelque chose
parce qu'il y en a sept rased rien c'est
pas trouver n'importe quoi droit de la
porte c'est trop vite ou ses marques et
aux marques peinture dans le ça ça fait
dire aujourd'hui pour moi je vous sur
certains c'est la personne et l'a écrit
si lui-même et l'a tué madame marche
pourquoi la famille marchal a choisi
pour s'attaquer à un jardinier marocain
sont beaucoup de de pouvoir visons
maître leclerc qui est quand même le
président de la ligue des droits de
l'homme c'est la question que pose moi
même parce que d'autres départs c'est
vrai rien à voir le personnage droits de
l'homme et après une dernière fois la
ans emilie la justice oui de départ ils
sont tous faits pour il n'a pas un
deuxième procès
aujourd'hui je pose la question à tout
le monde surtout à la famille de la
victime s qui sommes satisfaits la
personne est là tout y est madame
marchal comme ça est-ce qu'ils sont cet
esprit pour s'attarder présent ça serait
pas remis en question et si un deuxième
procès qui s'y prend le risque
personne n'est pas le risque c'est moi
d'y retourner a tourné au wac était
pourquoi lorsque vous avez écopé de 18
ans de prison
ce qui est beaucoup mais ce qui pour un
meurtre et - réclusion à perpétuité
pourquoi la famille de madame marchal
n'a pas protesté
c'est la question que pose moi même
parce que aujourd'hui le combat et
continuer pour moi pour ma famille et
aussi pour madame marchal parce qu'il
personne ne mérite de mourir comme ça et
aussi perso les mérites 18 heures parce
que j'étais désolé pas parce que c'est
grâce à la politique publique
c'est grâce à sa majesté hassan ii m
sous chirac mission
pourquoi les enquêteurs n'ont ils jamais
interroger votre oncle mimoun qui était
le majordome de madame marchal pendant
des années parce qu'aimer - ep hell
après la mort de madame marchal et la
demande d'avoir le jauge personnes les
côtés après cinq ans et l'a déclaré
qu'est-ce qui est madame marchal et la
mémoire et la dire à la presse
à côté ça la presse après la justice et
les anthologies mimoun là des paroles
qu'est ce qu'elle a dit à la presse va
dire à la justice après la justice et la
dct mois trop tard 1
mes skis et la justice et savent bien
mimoun que le travail est plus de satin
chez madame marchal et ça bien alors
pourquoi on pose pas la question
omar raddad
est-ce que vous avez été victime d'une
machination oui est ce que vous savez
qui a monté cette machination
non
savez pas où vous voulez pas le dire la
vérité je sais pas il faut pas à causer
je peux pas faire allégeance
je crois que c'est quelqu'un sans preuve
comme on m'a fait moi je moi je ne fais
pas ça vous ne rallume
bravo merci merci beaucoup
omar haddad
elle pourquoi moi
et c'est aux éditions du seuil
et maintenant qui va y avoir du sport
mais non
voici luis fernandez
al oui
bonsoir alors luis fernandez début de
saison détestable et deux ans après
votre retour au psg on a cru que vous
aviez être remplacé c'est le bruit qui
courait est ce qu'on disait c'est ce
qu'on fait on souhaitait peut-être aussi
parce que c'était c'est un peu la mode
au paris saint germain s'est changé
d'entraîneur tous les deux en garde on a
les images
c'était moi ça on avait plus nourris ce
que vous aviez être remplacés et on
était loin effectivement de cette grande
ambition de redevenir champion de france
et puis encore une fois comme d'habitude
vous avez sauvé votre peau après la
victoire du psg contre lyon le 4
décembre 2002 où le public d'ailleurs
n'a pas cessé de vous soutenir de
scander votre nom vous avez vraiment le
public avec vous laurent perpère a
décidé de vous maintenir à votre poste
et xavier couture et xavier couture
mais à son âme bien sûr pour voir si
c'était vrai film n'est ce pas officiel
encore si tout à fait avant je sais pas
la tête pas encore touché sans pognon
mais il est viré les informer comme
onfray regardant les images d
bon alors depuis la reprise de janvier
tout allait beaucoup mieux un psg
invaincu a bien entendu il y avait des
matches nuls mais pas de défaite c'est
une espèce d'état de grâce depuis depuis
la reprise après les fêtes
et puis mercredi soir à bastia c'est
après la défaite de cauchemar commence
non ils recommencent pas il faut savoir
perdre il faut savoir reconnaître c'est
la valeur de leur verser la glissière
course est un adversaire qui a fait
aussi un bon début d'année aussi c'est
tout le monde a perdu marseille les deux
autres calyon tous deux ont perdu
d'abord un 01 / but d'un ancien du psg
derrière florian maurice c'est vrai
qu'on a fait ce don de prêter des
joueurs ou de laisser partir la mort et
qui marquent notre toit après combien
l'on retrouve sur une autre à leur
chemin ils nous marquent des buts
première défaite après sept matches sans
défaite alors aujourd'hui on est à six
points de retard sur monaco
à onze journées de la fin qualifié en
coupe de france oui on a encore de
l'espoir quand même encore une
possibilité d'accrocher encore ce trio
de tête
oui je crois qu'on peut y arriver on est
mieux on a commencé l'année mieux et
l'équipe est il un meilleur état
d'esprit on sent les matchs de meilleure
qualité on pense qu'on peut encore avoir
une possibilité de revenir c'est dur
c'est très dur d'être entraînant au jour
d'aujourd'hui c'est très dur
le poste surtout énormément exposé
entraîneur c'est plus facile qu'avec
sarkozy pose planqué aussi quand même au
féminin et de mode alors les médias ils
ont comme habitude de refaire le match
ils refont le match ont revu le match il
adore ça on refait le match russie aux
jeunes c'est que maintenant
très très bien alors le match on refait
le même phénomène
serge prend le dessus et le garder pour
mon sens plaire mais aussi alors alors
c'est la notion de genre 1 2 3 ou de
gens me prennent pour un cinglé total
pas du tout c'est une émission
extraordinaire que je ne rate jamais sur
le site officiel
je la regarde pas assez vrai que le
dénommé en plus parce que tout mairie
qu'est ce qui t'a mis pour tous et il
savait seulement que lui 1 parce qu'ils
se donnent à coeur joie des nageurs là
c'est vraiment un grand connaisseur qui
connaissent tous qu'ils savent tout à
une émission
la seule chose dont on décide quand on
essaie d'avoir une conversation avec ces
messieurs là c'est de parler un peu du
jeu le football qui en somme ce qui est
plus intéressant pour un technicien
c'est d'essayer de d'avoir une discours
un langage quelque chose qui se rapporte
à ce que l'on fait ce qu'on essaye de
mettre en place tous les week-ends
mais ça les intéresse pas c'est eux
c'est une autre recherche est de savoir
pourquoi un tel ne joue pas pourquoi le
président ne fait pas ceci ou qui
commande qui dirige y ce qui les
intéresse c'est le déballage
systématique j'adore aux jeunes ans et
c'est un ami de longue date c'est bien
on va dire que nous sommes obligés de
signaler les carences de paris saint
germain ou d'autres clubs
quand il joue maintenant est une chose
aussi été très très bien chez eux c'est
que chacun de ses personnages
ils ont un club qu'ils ont à auxquels
ils sont très attachés
dicks éventuellement bondoux ne
fonctionne pas alors là ne t'inquiète
pas ils vont essayer de ça va être très
très court c'est par exemple un marche
bien on va parler qu'une minute si ça
marche mal on va parler pendant 15
minutes zahia mais sur les autres on est
un peu plus gentil non c'est vrai que
paris saint germain l'olympique de
marseille attire l'attention du public
on n'y peut rien donc il faut donner ce
que le public demande
on va pas parler et ils sont bons
sympathique et tout ça éternellement de
sedan 2-3 et de toutes ces équipes
éminemment sympathique et bon mais
pourtant public et public aime paris
saint-germain public à l'olympique de
marseille en tant que c'est pas des
choses on les dit alors ceux qui me que
jane ont revu le match comme ça toute la
journée
vous l'avez trouvé en amérique du sud
c'est vraiment non le ton des reportages
je les trouve en amérique du sud ça
c'est vrai mais ça c'est plutôt les
reportages de match là le côté polémique
je n'ai plus tôt trouvait en italie en
italie où il ya une émission très
célèbre qui s'appelle il progresse de
l'inédit dirigée par un homme et
biscuits à hardy et c'est un peu on
refait le match
ouais je posséde une wii possède une 1/2
procès du lundi d'ailleurs si on sait en
singeant jeunes saccomano georges
briquet grand grand grand commentateur
sportif des années 50 au lycée daudet à
nîmes que vous avez trouvé votre voix en
fait rien si je vous dit tout c'est en
avait un professeur de mathématiques qui
était sourd mais sourd comme c'est pas
possible
et le gros gag le gag est essentielle
c'était d'aller le voir
il dira je parlais baisser votre femme
s'il vous plaît et il disait toujours
attendait il y en a
vous irez bon et c'est pour dire l'état
de sa surdité et quand on s'est aperçu
très rapidement qu'il était sourde à ce
point moi je me suis mis à faire dans le
dans la classe des reportages de macho
et voilà c'est comme ça que ça a démarré
vous avez trouvé votre voix vous ai
trouvé votre voix ainsi ensuite il ya le
provençal il ya eu europe il ya eu rtl
lci etc
et à part ça je tiens gamme à signaler
au passage qu' il vous arrive de donner
dans la littérature la vraie avec
notamment un excellent roman qu'est paru
en 1999 qui s'appelle goncourt 32 et qui
raconte l'histoire de la nommer guy
mazeline qu'est le goncourt en 1932
contre céline séance extraordinaire le
mec il a été écrasé par son concurrent
et aujourd'hui on ne parle de mazine que
parce que vous avez fait ce bouquin
sinon on parle beaucoup plus de céline
effectivement là alors mercredi soir à
bastia alors mercredi soir joué par le
césar tout de suite dès le coup d'envoi
alors que il avait ce genre il y avait
joué un petit peu contre strasbourg
c'est déjà un nom avait déjà repris
depuis qu'un étang c'est un choix c'est
un choix de peut-être par rapport à une
certaine animation de jeu où on a besoin
d'un garçon comme par l'eau dans
l'entrejeu et ses fans n'avaient pas
joué depuis le 1er décembre pour pedro
parce que si je les fait venir c'est
qu'il ya un intérêt c'est un garçon qui
est gaucher qui peut prendre ce côté
gauche qui est intéressant d'ailleurs ce
qui peut nous apporter beaucoup
vous regrettez pas là non plus je vis
avec mes idées
ouais et je vais y est allés au bout de
leurs idées dans les mers et toi ça fait
dix ans que j'y suis et bon alors ça va
ça avec des hauts des bas on se
maintient à ce que je vois c'est
ronaldinho pourquoi il est resté si
longtemps sur le banc là il a eu du mal
aux dents et ait entraîné la selae cei
il a fallu mettre en place une
préparation spécifique individuel pour
lui pour essayer de lui faire retrouver
son niveau son niveau qui était celui de
la saison dernière celui qui nous a fait
gagner des matchs lui qui par sa qualité
sa sa technique peut encore et je pense
qu'il va revenir parce qu'il est en
train de faire des efforts et va
redevenir ce qu'il était
c'est une discussion mondial j'ai vu au
zapping des jeunes d'irakiens qui
discutaient entre eux du rôle de
ronaldinho au psg
la chance de le voir jouer à 20 parce
qu'il ne fait pas souvent jouer il était
pas mais qu'est ce que c'est cette
histoire pourquoi il fait pas plus jouer
ronaldinho aux jeunes fernandez luis
fernandez dit ceci ronaldinho est un
garçon qui n'est pas toujours tellement
sérieux qui a un peu disent non non le
che qui climat font cracher qui est
encore louis s'est dit qu'il y avait
plus de 90 au manque encore de condition
physique on à son physique et son
adjoint c'est sur ça que je juge à mort
c'est sur ce que je vois durand avait
payé qu'ils soient pas en bonne équipe
et je la seule chose c'est que moi je le
juge sur ce que je le vois à
l'entraînement sur le retard qu'il a et
puis je crois qu'il va redevenir qu'il
va refaire les efforts des petits bouts
de matches comme ça progressivement et
là par exemple depuis le début du mois
janvier de janvier je crois qu'au total
il a dû le faire jouer neuf minutes un
peu plus
non c'est pas vrai il a joué et joue et
112 minutes je crois on aldino mais
pedro qui lui n'avait joué que 9 minutes
la trêve depuis lance luis la ligne et
tout le match à lastours mais ma voix
ils n'étaient pas bastien il a dit la
ligne et tout le match
j'ai sorti à la 50e minute et ronde
alors tu lis pas les journaux
ce brave ronaldinho qui en fou et a
fracassé un joueur bastiais d'une façon
épouvantable et ils méritaient
totalement son carrosse à ses vrais
expulsé injustement jeu trop parce que
c'est plutôt un taux sur il se défend
plus plutôt qu'autre chose qu'on va
arrêter de mettre en cause des décisions
des arbitres franchement je crois que ce
sera les arbitres ils font très bien
leur travail
il a été blanchi vous savez je viens
c'est l'été non si je dis absolument
vous avez traité une arbitre
d'handicapés bal de ce côté là chez tran
qui n'est que je n'ai pas dit alors il
ya eu un carton aussi pour cristobal et
ce qui fait que le psg aujourd'hui -
recorman d'un truc c'est le nombre de
cartons rouges
on est pas mal de ce côté là carton
rouge depuis le début de la saison on
est leader à eymet môm'artre ans 13-14
donc avec un surcoût de france conquis
deux autres en coupe de l'uefa 16
cartons je suis bien là et on était
dépassé le champion du monde des cartons
rouges mesdames messieurs
voilà bon alors oui je pense
sérieusement effectivement vous avez été
blanchi par la commission de discipline
jeudi
mais c'est vrai que c'est quand même un
problème avec l'arbitrage là c'était
nelly viennot que vous aviez traité
d'handicapés non c'est comme ça s'est
produit il ya une discussion sur une sur
une action et puis la seconde année on a
eu avec les lits nous avait fait part
d'une proposition nous a fait une
demande pour un enfant qui était qui
avait un problème et on avait on avait
reçu l'enfant et l'enfant est décédé
trois semaines après ans pour ça comme
elle s'occupe d'une association penser
qu'ils sont pris d'une association
on lui avait répondu favorablement et
pour ça que quand on les dix ans sur le
banc attend avec l'association des
handicapés
attention nelly on a été gentils quand
même si on l'a pas employer un terme
pour essayer de lui faire du mal
fernandez et ses yeux bleus il raconte
les trucs tu comprends qu'elle juge de
l'émission dit si je disais mais les
musées nelly position elle a jugé et tu
connaissais mal à marshall toi
du magazine nous lis quand vous étiez
home est un gaz vous piquez une
mobylette et que si vous leur parlez
comme ça je comprends que les classer au
travers des mailles jours par les
marchés il a fallu écrire sur les fleurs
la porte du vestiaire c'est au saint
père m'a tuer il ya un autre truc avec
un peu plus grave c'est vrai qu'une fois
vous avez failli écraser enfin contre le
mur dans un parking un arbitre or ça
c'était et une enquête là-dessus et
j'étais aussi blanchi bin une tendance à
me chercher ou actuellement qui est
celle qui est passionné qui s à paris
saint germain hier fernandez et
ronaldinho alors les deux stars
l'ambiance il joue et nous trouver un
qui joue c'est fernandez qui joue là tu
n'es tu vas pas dire que je peux pas
supporter dans la nuit parce que c'est
quand même un garçon qu'on a repris la
saison d'année avec eux et qu'il a quand
même été au championnat du monde il
était champion du monde
suite au travail qu'on a réussi avec lui
quand même fait des clashs veut dès
qu'ils jouent alors tu peux passer
devant thomas au contraire on aimerait
le retrouver comme il était la saison
d'année à temps quel est l'entraîneur
qui va se priver d'un champion du monde
tu le connais toi celui-là c'est
peut-être peut-être été nombreux ces
grands numéros de la vérité est là
on pourrai pas vous périrez lui marc
allard
highland moi j'aime et j'ai commencé à
chauffer et enfin dans les temps
qui sait
alors il ya un truc c'est vrai que quand
vous êtes exclu du banc de touche luis
vous diriger le match avec un petit
portable comme ça de plus loin et très
très haut
c'est vrai c'est insupportable c'est dur
à vivre un mois j'ai besoin d'être sur
le bord du terrain vous avez quoi des
jumelles un écran de télé comme en fait
non de de la haute volée il faut le
match c'est qu'en angleterre les
managers se mettre dans la tribune en
point mi temps est bon et ferguson
descend en deuxième mi temps sur le banc
bord du doigt parce qu'ils ont une
impression de de mieux voir le départ
d'un match et mieux voir et d'analyser
décembre le placement de l'équipe s'il
est bien placé et ensuite de rectifier à
la mi temps
bon moi j'aime bien tout de suite être
là au bord du terrain comment ça va avec
laurent perpère ça va bien très bien oui
mais pas de problème de ce côté-là c'est
un homme que j'apprécie bien dommage
qu'il s'en aille en même temps alors
pour rêver sur n'irait pas parce que
maintenant ça va être vendu tous à lacer
mes deux accords l'un pas te dire alors
ouais bah c est eux qui pourrait me dire
me gêne vous prévoyez quoi comme
classement pour psg c'est tellement
d'autres produits non non je ne crois
pas je crois pas je croyais pas mais pas
vidé et peuvent y arriver parce que dans
la dernière
l'un de mes camarades dans ce petit
théâtre donc a dit ceci qui était très
intéressant aider l'équipe de luis elle
ressemble finalement à celle d'arthur
georges dao début des années 90 c'est à
dire que les résultats sont là peuvent
être là mais on s'emmerde terriblement
jeu
il va falloir terminer premier ou
deuxième
il va peut-être faire la ligue des
champions mais il n'empêche que c'est
assez triste hausse ce qui est bien
c'est que tu es un grand connaisseur de
football
c'est pour ça que je respecte énormément
ce que tu as a fait beaucoup de matches
que je vois mais oui mais c'est ça c'est
que j'ai joué à leur premier regard part
de là tu étais pas la toute première
gambardella la toute première 1954 connu
mais je sais pas de quoi vous parlez
justement on va profiter du fait que
vous soyez là tous les deux lluis gêne
pour faire les questions interdites du
foot français
[Musique]
est ce que le championnat de france est
bien le plus mauvais championnat
d'europe
hier cinq nations qui pratiquent le
football de haut niveau en europe en
angleterre italie espagne allemagne et
forains la france actuellement
effectivement cette cinquième européen
c'est le cinquième européen
pourquoi parce que les mecs jouent à
l'étranger parce que dans ces pays là
que gêne il ya quand même il ya des
facilités a quand même des avantages
qu'en france on a pas et sur ça on objet
de lutter les avantages non pas ça parce
qu'il ya quand même certains
aménagements parce que j'ai vécu
j'étais quand même le championnat
espagnol pendant quatre ans après j'ai
pu s'en gardent la différence avec le
championnat français c'est totalement
différent
c'est davantage la balle est footballeur
il peut s'allier à 519 par exemple déjà
conclus en espagne tu as quand même ce
ce phénomène qui est l'autonomie des
autonomies de région dans le mille base
que ton ami catalan est automatiquement
dans ces autonomies les clubs les dans
ces régions les clubs sont énormément
favoriser on leur donne les moyens qu'il
faut éventuellement pour pouvoir
recruter pour pouvoir les noms mais
après ce problème d'argent
c'est vos problèmes d'argent savoir
qu'en france les charges sur les clubs
sont énormes
donc ils ne peuvent pas payer les
joueurs comme les clubs étrangers les
pieds ça s'est arrêté un peu de lait
payé un peu trop quand même c'est parce
que les champions du monde nos meilleurs
joueurs sont quand même à l'étranger ce
qui reste quand même pas les meilleures
le championnat ceux qui restent sont
crevés d'europe à la voile a alors
deuxième question allez pour vous et
luis fernandez
les vraies raisons entre nous les yeux
dans les yeux les vraies raisons de la
défaite des bleus au corps et au corps
est certainement qu'un joueur comme
zizou n'était pas à 100% avec une
blessure est content d'un garçon c'est
zinédine zidane non mais c'est important
c'est comme si tu enlèves à réal de
madrid un rat au loin
à la jules del piero et on va sentir
tout de suite ce qui nous a fait ça fait
que le groupe ne peut pas on se repose
toujours sur ce garçon mais quand on
voit le talent qu'il a et l'apport qu'il
a dans le groupe
ça fait énormément c'est la première
raison les autres après on peut pas
toujours incriminer comme l'entraîneur
il ya quand même aussi il y en a
énormément de données ou de responsables
de la préparation peut-être peut-être
que moi je pense que personnellement ce
match amical qui était programmé c'était
encore est commémorée savourer quelques
jours avant le savez peut-être pas
n'avait peut-être pas raison de lieux de
presse que vous me dites là luis
fernandez c'est une île est fini
l'alcool
non non je pense pas non je crois pas je
crois pas que les garçons soient parties
d'abord en poursuite et cela finit dans
pub il ya aussi aussi le côté ou quand
les championnes et monter un arrêté à
temps et automatiquement les sénégalais
se sont quand ce ne sont pas des mauvais
jours bonjour ils jouent tous dans notre
championnat ou dans des championnats
étrangers
et c'est pour ça que c'est important
quand tu commences à une compétition
ensuite ça s'enchaîne mal
luis est ce que vous touchez du blé de
la marque de sucettes
non à mon nom pourtant vous êtes sans
arrêt dire non je peux pas dire le havre
à dire non pas des noms mais ont envoyé
des dons jouer intensément à des causes
de ce phénomène me plaît pas c'est sûr
on y offre mêmes
n'est-il pas temps aux jeunes saccomano
que thierry roland et jean michel larqué
prennent leur retraite
non je crois pas et je le dis très
sincèrement que je le dis très
sincèrement parce que sur le commentaire
des matchs de football
thierry est encore au loin le meilleur
c'est louis ce qui rend fou non mais
j'ai renflement moi je m'endors et
et quant à l'arc et bat larqué il
explique bien aux jeunes saccomano un
succès continu des voix bien l'énerver
toi quand il parlait dans ses
commentaires à la radio et par excès
mais on n'a pas non plus enlever quand
même que thierry et jean michel ont
quand même énormément apporté au
bêtisier surtout est ce que le football
féminin à un vrai intérêt
oui oui il a un gros intérêt
d'abord c'est le sport c'est un des
sports les plus pratiqués aux états unis
alors ce qui est un peu désolant pour
nous les machos européens surtout latin
c'est de savoir que aux états unis on
considère le football comme un sport de
gonzesses 1 ce qui est épouvantable et
c'est vrai que ce sont les filles qui
font l'essentiel du football aux états
unis
elles sont d'ailleurs tu vois qu'ils ont
sur les coups francs parce qu'on voit
les mecs qui se protègent les couilles
comme en grèce qu'elle faisons le même
geste à sewen tech les seins elles ont
des des soutiens gorges or c'est vrai
nom mais celle ci présente sur la chasse
you un peu spéciaux quelquefois comme
les avait laissées est ce que guy roux
ne suis pas trop de pub à la télé à me
roux c'est mon ami lula d'or oui et non
il fait pas beau coup de pub à et roger
ribo coup sûr à trop j'ai vu ces jeunes
ils avaient beaucoup la question c'est
trop il ramasse il ramasse le ramasse la
peur d'en perdre en chemin
et donc s'il est comme ça pourquoi pas
hein
il dit qu'il n'est pas comme ça hein
mais il est comme ça il est exceptionnel
il est formidable et formidable non
l'argent
moi j'aime beaucoup est-ce que supporter
une équipe de football
roncq ont je crois que c'est terrible de
dire ça mais je crois que quand même
quelques fois sans se montre bien selon
est-ce que je joue avec des franges
qu'on connaisse que leur disait demain
je pense que non c'est à dire qu'il est
difficilement il était une ruche
facilement compréhensibles donc il
fallait être très très fort pour saisir
les subtilités du discours de m
c'est pas très gentil devient champion
du monde avec le roger lemerre comme
d'aimé jacquet s'en va que roger lemerre
pensant qu'on dorme sont champions
d'europe et que ce soir-là contre
l'italie en finale il a un coup de génie
de coaching de changer deux jours et ces
deux joueurs amènent ce but vainqueur
c'est quand même c'est le maire qui fait
le coach a exactement étoiles et les
planètes chez ces gens là je vais te dit
raymond a été champion d'europe après
avoir été champion du monde et ça c'est
vraiment ces français c'est comme ça
c'est ici c'est ce que vous avez un jour
ou l'autre après vous le détruisent et
où le boulet c'est comme ça par rapport
à ce que j'ai vu il ya un respect de dés
des joueurs qui ont joué dans les années
60 ou qui sont encore et qu'on respecte
et qu'on sait c'est dans l'histoire
c'est dans la tradition
si c'est ça se perd ça ça n'existe pas
le dépôt d'un nom et son nom
eugène saccomano
hoffenheim
[Musique]
et luis fernandez sur les ailes on
et maintenant
[Musique]
moi jai routier
il est
[Musique]
et
je hais authier bonsoir vous êtes
rédacteur en chef au nouvel observateur
où vous suivez les questions économiques
et vous est aussi l'auteur de
best-sellers consacré à bernard tapie à
la sphère elf le fameux forages en eaux
profondes que vous avez écrit avec
valérie lecasble et vous publié chez
albin michel
un livre qui s'appelle l'ange
exterminateur la vraie vie de bernard
arnault
alors dans l'ange exterminateur vous
raconter comment bernard arnault le
patron de lvmh qui est parti il ya vingt
ans d'une pme de province est devenu
l'homme le plus riche de france voilà
enfin d'après ce que vous écrivez
on a maintenant tellement de problèmes
avec les avocats avec ce bouquin que je
vais dire d'après ce que vous écrivez
tout mes phrases vont commencer par
d'après vous où est-il exact où vous
affirmez et laurent je compte sur toi on
fera de rectifier si je commençais bon
d'accord vous affirmer tout humain
j'entends bien je suis sur le court je
viens juste de touche d'un petit
la [ __ ] à mi temps je vais dire à mes
amis téléspectateurs c'est que toute
façon ce qui est dans le bouquin on peut
pas vraiment le raconter à la télé alors
faites moi confiance
achetez le voilà comme ça au moins c'est
clair c'est terry routier merci alors
plus sérieusement vous écrivez z'auriez
écrit oui que bernard arnault a tout
fait pour empêcher la la sortie du livre
et plusieurs patrons vous ont fait
clairement savoir que en publiant ce
bouquin vous mettiez votre avenir
professionnel en danger si je ne
publiait pas je mettais mon avenir
personnel variable l'establishment vous
serais reconnaissant de il ya déjà
plusieurs livres consacrés bernard
arnault qui ne sont jamais sortis
oui il y en a eu 1 chez odile jacob et
ainsi robert laffont voilà absolument
alors été obligés aussi airy routier de
changer d'éditeur grasset qui est l
éditeur de votre livre précédent a
préféré passer le bébé albin michel
oui ça s'est passé de façon assez
harmonieuse mais j'ai tout d'un coup
j'ai compris que si j'allais au bout je
crois qu'ils ont été au bout mais j'aime
ça les arrangeait but d'ailleurs
religieux ne râlent pas trop grasse elle
m'a dit keith un m'a dit écoute rugby
quand on veut marquer un essai qui est
un gros master en face d'un vaut mieux
passer la balle que ce pays et le master
fait un gros set et donc ça c'est fait
gentil non donc c'est alain michel qui
sort le bouquin pas parce qu'ils sont
plus courageux ils ont moins peur des
masses tard chez albin michel
j'ai l'impression qu'à logiciel est dans
une phase assez offensive
alors on vous a aussi accusé les
routiers de rouler pour françois pinault
qui est le grand ennemi de bernard
arnault cet idiot parce que ringer pas
besoin de deux parrains comme pino pour
faire mon job
2 les trois quarts du bouquin sont quand
même avant qui nous arrive donc je vois
comment il aurait pu l'aider
3-3 face non mais c'est la mentalité des
grands patrons jamais ils imaginent
qu'on puisse faire une démarche normale
d'un journaliste normal est anormal à
l'américaine vous raconter que pendant
votre travail vous avez eu affaire à des
gens absolument terrifiée kivu
donner des rendez-vous dans des endroits
absolument ultra secret oui il ya une
part de 60 il a la pression
bernard membe sur les gens avec qui il
travaille ou ceux avec qui il a
travaillé ce qui l'a perdu de vue depuis
vingt ans j'ai passé des coups de fil me
rappelle un design on peut pas on veut
pas mais c'était sénat c'est assez
étonnant il ya une vraiment un climat
autour de lui deux à la fois de respect
d'ailleurs de rester pour le personnage
qui est quand même extrêmement de
cuisson et la crainte c'est que les
alors dans le livre vous dites non vous
affirmez c'est ça que je veux dire vous
supputer hk
les avocats vont ils supputer que
bernard arnault utilise non mais ça vous
le savez si tu t'es utilisent les
services d'une agence de détectives qui
s'appelle l'agent scroll alors c'est
quoi la gent scroll c'est une agence qui
a été créé à la fin des années 70 quand
jimmy carter a voulu faire le ménage
dans la cia dont il a géré la moitié des
agents de la cia qui sont regroupés
qu'on fait une agence qui reste
extrêmement lié la cia quai dans le
monde entier et qu'à une activité
d'espionnage économique extrêmement
puissante
donc j'ai effectivement c'est pas des
supputations
j'ai consulté les documents et tout si
vous avez eu accès à des documents
internes de l'agent scroll et le patron
d'ailleurs françois waldman a été viré
merci bravo la fosse du bouquin mais non
mais c'est c'est d'être atik qui sont
plus fréquentes on le croit mais fall
bears impulsant quand on voit les
documents sa glace un peu ça le ferait
de l'arno c'est que comme il est il a
une image extrêmement lisse qui veut ils
veulent se donner une image de lui
parfaite
bon il y avait double langage donc dans
donc c'est très très surprenant quoique
quand au même moment il dit du un bien
fou de tom ford de mikko est solide ce
sont les patrons de boutiques qui veut à
l'époque qu'ils veulent et les bouffer
et en même temps lvmh passe un contrat
crawl pour les fous pour les
disqualifier en fait ils trouvent rien
d'ailleurs coin à un moment quand il
voulait racheter vit-on le patron à
l'époque était monsieur henri racamier
un vieux monsieur comme ça très vieille
france et tous les journaux de france et
de navarre ont reçu une lettre de
penn remerciant monsieur racamier pour
les dons qu'ils avaient fait pour sa
campagne c'est un fou c'est un faux le
canard il avait publié à l'époque et ses
six mois après s'était excusé c'était un
faux le pen tient jours après bildt le
pen devait être assez content de voir ça
aussi donc il a mis trois semaines à
démentir un mais ça a été démenti cette
info et elle et les photos de la
boutique vuitton en 1942 avec vieilles
photos qui sont arrivés dans pas mal de
rédaction avec marc est interdit aux
juifs c'était un faux nom c'est vrai
mais c'était jeu je pensais drilles
france comme beaucoup de boutiques
qu'elle est moins marqué ça mais c'était
un amalgame terrible car vous n'êtes pas
peur et les routiers que monsieur
bernard arnault couple la publicité
qu'il fait dans le nouvel observateur
journal qui vous emploie non j'ai pas
peur
j'ai pas peur parce que il est où ce
stupide que ça se retournerait contre
lui quand plus routier ces outils l'obs
elop je pense pas qu'ils feraient ça
facile le fait s'est il fait une bêtise
en plus je ferai plus drôle c'est quand
même excellent support de plus pour les
marques
0e h6 déjà qu'il en donne pas au pain
parce que c'est pinault qui en donne pas
à l'express c'est un peu court
alors pourquoi l'ange exterminateur
quand on le voit il est parfait des gens
qui est merveilleux il est calculé
placide il est bon bien que l'ombrageux
il est susceptible et il est faux comme
ça bon mais quand on regarde la réalité
des fêtes
c'est un tueur et il a c'est un pur eux
il a peur d'être tués mais il a peur
d'être battus la peur d'être agressés et
donc qui tue avant d'être tué art et un
lucky luke maintenant la question que
tout le monde se pose
[Musique]
comment fait-on pour devenir aussi riche
ah ça c'est compliqué face sinon c'est
tout le monde le ferait ouais donc on
pourrait d'abord on part avec 40
millions cède ces entreprises familiales
par exemple millions bon c'est une
entreprise de construction ce qui n pas
d'argent on la vend on prend 40 millions
fait d'entreprise de promotion férinel à
la mer série men firenena la montagne
série ne se souvient pas de ça ici c'est
comme ça c'est bon et ensuite on prend
contrôle de boussac
ouais on arrive avec son son blazer bleu
ses boutons dorés son père provincial
avec un projet précis alors qu'il ya
tout un maelström des gens qui veulent
bouffer boussac et tous ne veulent que
dior on arrive avec une tête d'enfant
fabius vous donne bout 7 1 ça aide
ensuite donc on tient quand c'est bien
donc ensuite
ensuite on tient pas ses promesses on
vend tout tout ce qui est de la laine le
textile et son garde dior conforama trop
douce et puis ensuite cinq six ans après
et lvmh et de il ya deux patrons qui se
battent entre eux on va entre les deux
on fait plein vers là on va vers l'autre
ont joué l'un contre l'autre et tout
d'un coup on emprunte 25 milliards au
trigone et en deux jours il fait partie
de ces grands patrons français qui ont
réussi grâce auprès des banques en fait
auprès du crédit lyonnais même écrit à
des noms n'est pas prise et il a
remboursé plus sollicités il faut quand
même osé emprunter 1,25 milliard de
jours ils n'avaient pas le premier sou
enfin il est bon et il prend lvmh est
ensuite alors il ya des ensuite scellé
mécanisme extrêmement compliqué non
qu'on peut pas ainsi mais il ya des
cascades tout comme ça fait de l'argent
c'est comme la france d'où la france du
bas il ya des cascades des actionnaires
minoritaires et du meilleur du dot
l'argent du bas va en eau
plus vite qu'il ne devrait semble-t-il
oui donc apparemment ce n'est pas à la
portée de tout le monde
puis 40 millions de départ c'est quand
même c'est pas inutile vous expliquez ça
très bien alors il ya deux raisons donc
d'acheter le bouquin déry routier l'ange
exterminateur la vraie vie de bernard
arnault chez albin michel
la première baisse est d'abord tout
savoir sur l'homme le plus riche de
france parce que c'est pas effectivement
très connu ce que vous racontez
et puis la deuxième c'est d'essayer de
faire parler de faire comme lui voilà
merci beaucoup d'énergie et les routiers
[Musique]
et
et maintenant quoi j'aime pas
[Musique]
à
dalli
j'accueille saskia mühleberg
[Musique]
m
et
jamais or vers la chine
bon c'est ce qui est inutile de le
cacher plus longtemps vous êtes la soeur
de karen mulder la regardera ans
on peut y lire elle va bien et vous
comment vous allez bah moi ça va très
bien bon très bien très bien
eh bien oui j'ai pas pété les plombs là
ça va bon c'est pas trop dur d'être la
soeur d'une star pas évident c'est à
dire que c'est par exemple un moment je
faisais un peu de mannequinat et le
moitié du photographe m'a appelé par son
nom
parfois j'étais un bon c'est comme ça il
faut dire c'est ce qu'a mulder que vous
êtes connus mais en angleterre pour une
série télé qui s'appelle the book group
social fort où vous jouez les pouces
d'un footballeur
elle durait dans un truc pas céder notre
énorme car elle joue l'épousé d'un
footballeur qui découvrent d'autres
horizons
après avoir lu l'alchimiste de paulo
coelho comment il est alors dans la
série votre mari footballeur les
footballeur dans une serre il est
entièrement fausse idée de lui même je
pense que c'est le prototype mauvais
qu'on a validé marais de des soupes à
l'heure et moi aussi au début d'ailleurs
donc voilà ça vous aviez réservé des
footballeurs mauvaise idée des
footballeurs bas parfois vos sélections
il ya beaucoup de footballeurs qui ont
qui lisent pas aux locaux et aux bras
qu'on n'a jamais vus paulo coelho lire
les mémoires de luis fernandez
c'est ce qu'a fait ce cas quelle
mauvaise idée vous avez sur les
footballeur votre personnage quelle
mauvaise idée ma personnage elle les
trouve qu'ils sont très cons que la vie
que ça va au delà que la physique balisé
par locaux l'eau voilà pour oublier son
mari footballeur alors vous parlez très
très bien le français ce cas parce que
vous avez vécu à paris où vous avez fait
d'abord des études d'économie aux pays
bas et puis un jour vous êtes sur votre
bicyclette vous aller à l'université
et vous faites demi tour bah oui je me
suis rendu compte que c'était hyper
chiant et je me suis dit bon voilà si
c'est vers ça ad'abord encore trois
années dix balles dans ma tête et ans
après le métier de banquier semaine
j'avais pas compris ciel qui lie paulo
coelho le personnage un personnage qui
est un footballeur serait plus normal on
fait garde alternée là tu le prends un
jeune that thing
[Rires]
donc elle va à l'université sur sa
bicyclette
l'ordre est donc un moment elle fait
demi tour pour passer chez vous vous
prenez vos valises et vous venez à paris
pour prendre des cours de théâtre
mais évidemment pour payer le loyer le
reste vous un peu de mannequinat
voilà ce qui a été pour moi parfait
parce que comme ça je n'étais pas trop
pauvre vous passez directement donc de
l'université en hollande à la vie de
bohème à paris au sixième étage sans
ascenseur une chambre de bonne
vous avez jamais été un mannequin star
n'ont pas déjà j'aimais pas trop ça
j'avais toujours quand les gens me
demander ce que je fais et je devais
dire mannequin je sais pas ça ne me
rendais pas de touche hier c'était
vraiment pas mon truc et je pense que
j'étais pas très bien non plus conclut
salut avoir quelque chose à dire qu'on
peut pas faire tout un sas qui a été
plutôt spécialisé dans les catalogues
dans femme actuelle rima
voilà c'était pas beau gars non c'est
vrai on agit de l'avouer j'étais j'étais
pas bien du tout ouais ça jamais
vraiment très très bien marché juste de
quoi vivre quoi c'était le but je pense
et moi ce qui m'intéressait c'était de
gagner de la un peu d'argent oui c'était
ça oui pour vous ce n'est pas un art
comme pour certaines top model voilà
voilà
ça va là oui je vais pas pété les plombs
là ça va parce qu'on m'a parlé de votre
enfance là
ça c'est [ __ ] donc votre truc quand
vous étiez petit c'était d'être ni top
model il a dans la musique contrairement
à karen mulder mais effectivement
d'écrire
franchement quand j'étais petit mon truc
c'était de jouer dehors dans un
penthouse jouer au foot c'est pas du
tout on entend qu'il rêvait déjà de
voile avons peut-être ai-je bien que
faire une carrière de mannequin pour des
chemises
non c'est vrai c'était votre truc j'ai
cru que sérieux bâton oui c'est ça dans
la vie voilà c'est bien quand j'étais
petit déjà je mets bien écrit j'adorais
fermé des pièces de théâtre mais je me
disais pas voilà je vais être écrivain
non mais vous écriviez quand même
régulièrement et un jour vous êtes heure
assez marrant parce qu'on aime parler de
huit ont avec les routiers un jour vous
êtes chez vuitton vous est ce qu'on
appelle mu c'est à dire que les
créateurs de titres avec marc jacobs
font une robe sur vous un boulot c'est
de rester debout
vous êtes muse et à ce moment là il ya
un des créateurs qui bosse dans cet
atelier et qui vous montrer ce que vous
avez commencé dans ce travail on avait
des heures d'attentes qui était bon vous
souhaitez vraiment des heures donc pour
mam pour m'amuser j'ai commencé à écrire
ce que je fais toujours pour m'amuser
j'écris des histoires et en d autres
créateurs à ma demande et alors est ce
que je peux dire ce que tu écris à
trouver c'est très marrant mama m'a
donné envie d'être continuer et comme ça
à la fin du boulot je pense que ça
durait six semaines je vais presque la
première chapitre voilà et ça donne ça
[Musique]
voilà c'est le livre de sesca mulder ça
s'appelle même super woman appris à
voler et c'est chez oh éditions 1
voilà alors le pitch de le faire tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Rires]
et
petit fini c'est l'histoire d'une petite
fille riche 1 s'appelle chloé
bah oui c'est de l'histoire d'une fille
qui en sortent antibruit jones et a le
cul parfait qui en ligne et d'hommes qui
veulent sortir avec elle qui est
richissime et à certains moments on se
rend compte qu'il ya bien plus dans la
vie que ça et elle va à la recherche de
ce que c'est la chance de sa vie qu'elle
quoi faire pour être heureux et elle le
fait bon avec beaucoup d'humour est sûr
c'est très long parce que excusez moi
téléspectateurs elle décide donc
effectivement de plus être entretenue
par son père de se prendre en main et
donc elle renvoie son prof de gym son
psy sa femme de ménage sa voyante sa
coiffeuse ses amis donc voilà ouais
ouais voilà ses débuts et on a ensuite
eu qu'à plein de mecs mais non ça va
owona casa à oui t'as pour nous les
français c'est par hollande
bah oui mais quand même là j'étais un
peu choqué en lisant debout qu'un mois
c'est vous choque
déjà ya pas des descriptions d'ailleurs
c'est un peu ce qu'on peut regretter il
n'ya pas des descriptions très précises
pratique pour se caresser mais c'est
choquant
il ya quand même pas mal de l'histoire
d'amour non prof ça va je vois
personnellement son film est bon pour
vous cela normal
continuez continuez continuez racontez
nous l'histoire de votre livre on vous
écoute c'est ce qu'a donc voilà on a
maintenant le livrons ce huis clos et
qui fait donc cette cette quête de bons
qu'est ce que c'est de la science de la
vie elle va trouver plein de choses qui
sont très importants pour elle donc au
début sur laquelle va trouver une
elle veut trouver un travail pour avoir
carte de visite canaux en fait elle fait
tout pour plaire à les autres est
incertain mois elle apprend les choses
sur sur de l'amitié et la prend a donné
elle apprend elle s'y trouve en fait
donc fini par ouvrir un restaurant mais
comme ça finit bien tout réussi pour
elle
le restaurant est plein dès le jour de
l'inauguration voilà bah écoute c'est la
fin suffit de finir je vais pas lui
raconter non maintenant à 8 h tél
c'est dommage alors il ya un certain
nombre de trouvailles de langage
dans ce livre qui ne manqueront pas de
vous intéresser mon cher laurent page 71
chloé apprend que son père veut quitter
sa mère parce que ses parents d'hiver
durent elles sont fait pas parce qu'elle
se dit d'autant plus libre que mes
parents ne seront plus ensemble et alors
elle appelle son père ce bâtard gluant
ce bâtard clubs se battent arguments
ouais bah écoutez cela c'est la
traductrice page 33 elle casse le talent
de ses chaussures hors de prix
évidemment en piétinant sa carte bleue
devant son père saloperie de merde
ouais c'est bien trouvé brasse et vous
ça vous d'accord les pages 204 il tenait
la télécommande d'une main tandis que
l'autre recouvrer ses couilles
la classe est une position assez
masculin le truc
ouais je sais pas si vous vous trouvez
parfois l'ancienne
ces scanners même super romane appris à
voler chez oh éditions messieurs
j'accueille maintenant basile boli
[Musique]
pourquoi
basile boli bonsoir bonsoir bien basile
boli donc ancien international français
vous dirigez aujourd'hui une société de
marketing sportif et je vous ai demandé
de venir ce soir ici basile boli parce
que vous êtes ivoirien
vous êtes né à abidjan et parce que vous
avez lancé dernièrement un appel à
jacques chirac
[Musique]
je vous fais une lettre que vous lirez
si vous
nous amener
alors basile boli vous remettez en cause
les fameux accords de marcoussis
alors je fais un rappel rapide pour les
gens qui ont pas suivi l'actualité de la
côte d'ivoire ces derniers temps depuis
la mi septembre
la côte d'ivoire est coupée en deux au
nord il ya des rebelles qui sont
musulmans au sujet des forces loyalistes
qui sont fidèles au président élu
laurent gbagbo
et entre les deux il ya l'armée
française qui fait tampon après avoir
fait barrage à la déferlante nordiste il
ya 2500 français des soldats là-bas et
bientôt 3000 et c'est là que le ministre
des affaires étrangères dominique de
villepin organise près de paris à linas
marcoussis
une réunion avec toutes les parties
prenantes du conflit ivoirien voilà et
lors de cette réunion les partisans du
président ivoirien ont accepté que
d'importants ministères soient confiées
à des rebelles depuis le président
ivoirien est resté muet
son épouse a dit qu'elle n'acceptait pas
les accords de marcoussis et ses proches
disent que la france a forcé la main au
président ivoirien voilà il ya des
français qui sont obligés aujourd'hui de
quitter la côte d'ivoire menacé et on
parle aussi des escadrons de la mort qui
serait la garde prétorienne du président
ivoirien voilà ça c'est la situation
donc vous vous dites chirac
j'aurais bien aimé que marcoussis se
passe en afrique ouais parce que c'est
un problème africain
j'aurais rêvé de voir les politiques
ivoiriens qui s'embrassaient qui
chantait l'abidjanaise à marcoussis
j'aurais bien aimé que ce soit à abidjan
1 ou dans un petit village à l'africaine
et que les africains prennent en main
leur destin
deuxièmement je remet en cause la france
parce que elle devait jouer son rôle de
médiateur et ce qui est normal vu nos
liens avec la france est parce que l ael
attardé même avec les ressortissants
français elle a eu du mal à les faire
venir en france et ils étaient obligés
de payer eux mêmes leur leur billet
c'est pour vous dire que beaucoup de
choses qui n'ont pas marché
les liens entre la côte d'ivoire et la
france c'est assez mois en gros les
habitants jouent en équipe de france
c'est c'est une partie de moi quand je
vois des pancartes anti français en côte
d'ivoire
ça veut dire que là quelque chose qui va
pas or la côte d'ivoire c'est presque la
france
je suis pas venu jouer la langue de bois
ici
direct mes amis je connaisse et ce qui
se passe dans mon pays aujourd'hui
d'origine c'est ça va pas ça va pas
parce qu'il ya une haine entre les
partis politiques et haine entre vous
avez dit le nord et le sud etc
y'a pas de religion en cause je sais
votre père musulman j'ai donc ça pour
vous dire que nous aujourd'hui on pleure
no more en pleurs une guerre on plaît en
pleurs la côte d'ivoire qui est détruite
et ça on n'a pas envie que ça se sa
continue vous dites c'est une déception
de voir le pays des droits de l'homme
données des ministères aussi important
que l'intérieur et la défense à des
rebelles à des caporaux et des sergents
mais qui n'ont aucune notion politique
ces signalements c'était plus et c'est
un peu normal parce que est ce que vous
imaginez les soldats qui ont de petits
se sont battus pendant une semaine des
écus retrouve en face leurs frères leurs
frères parce que parmi leurs beignes à
les ivoiriens il faut pas l'oublier
voilà et c'est ça se ferme pas comme ça
il ya eu des morts et les morts chez
nous en afrique on les respecte
on peut le faire la paix qu'avec ses
ennemis dont baisser un moment là la
france veut pas défendre dominique de
villepin mais c'est vrai qu'à un moment
la france a essayé de raccommoder tout
ça d' arranger tout ça mais elle a tardé
est là il ya une lassitude c'est ce que
je sais pas si elle ne s'est pas de dire
que la france et les nus de la côte du
board pas du tout au contraire
vous dites que vous en voulez à la
france finalement d'avoir fait rentrer
des rebelles dans le gouvernement comme
ministre de la défense miniser
l'intérieur mais si on veut trouver une
solution pour arrêter je suis d'abord
arrêter ces bières cl mais il faut bien
à un moment qu'il y ait des rebelles qui
rentre dans le gouvernement et un
président de la république
il a nommé un premier ministre accepté
par tous les partis politiques - ok mais
ce se prémunissent les su le faire son
gouvernement aux séances et hausse
on s'est tu et on s'est fait ça au jour
les partis voir un médiateur en france
il nous a dit çà çà çà çà çà on rentre
chez nous et puis on se réunit on est
bon on veut plus on ne pourront plus de
ça on n'a pas envie que giula attaque un
bété ou un bété atacama
on ne veut plus de ça je forme mon
gouvernement alors là c'est notre
affaire à tous c'est notre verre dans ce
que vous reprochez et finalement la
france certaine façon c'est d'avoir
constitué le gouvernement ivoirien à ces
territoires même accepter ça en même
temps les mecs qui décide ici de kiss ou
qu'ils veulent qui va être ministre qui
va pas être ministre
non et c'est ça le problème oui passé
quand même des ivoiriens qui est discuté
à mark bell mais oui d'accord mais
avec avec des influences s'ils sont si
soit en côte d'ivoire qui voyait
vraiment que les jeunes de
de 9 à 15 ans vont vont se battre et que
donc on leur dit votre pays est en train
de brûler mais ils vont y réfléchir
d'accord donc j'ai compris ce que vous
dites c'est que si la réunion de
marcoussis s'était passé en afrique
finalement il aurait été plus conscients
qu'on pouvait pas mettre des rebelles
communistes dans la défense ou qu'au
ministre de l'intérieur parce que tout
de suite dans la rue et rue des
réactions exacte sans attendre si
finalement c'est eric sans attendre
après d'accord ok si on est d'accord
mais maintenant les rebelles veut ils
s'impatientent ils disent il ya eu des
accords à marcoussis
pourquoi on les respecte pas pourquoi
nous nous sommes à nous sont pas
ministre de l'intérieur émile de la
défense premier point ces rebelles
maintenant ils attendent de rentrer dans
le gouvernement à abidjan
et deuxièmement le conseil de sécurité
de l'onu a reconnu les accords de
marcoussis donc maintenant de toute
façon c'est quelque chose qui est rentré
dans un engrenage je dirais on voit bien
avec l'irak ce qui se passe c'est
rentrer dans un engrenage internationale
avec la grosse machine de l'onu alors
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire maintenant
est ce qu'on va faire je pense que avec
l'intelligence politique qu'il a le
président gbagbo
il va comprendre que son pays est en
train de voler et que et il faut il faut
lâcher du lest
je pense que dans les jours à venir on
aura une discussion peut-être un
consensus entre les partis politiques
ivoiriens que vous reprochez en fait
c'est que la faire c'est pas réglé entre
africains c'est ça que vous regrettez
ainsi un peu ouais un peu oui oui ça
qu'il a fallu aller chercher le grand
frère pour aider à résoudre
aussi même si on a toujours besoin de
lui oui il y avait doute d'autres de
pression un tu aurais pu faire pour
pouvoir nous et mirent alors maintenant
les ivoiriens et les habitants d'abidjan
en particulier
ils en veulent à la france ils en
veulent aux français les puces de ses
vrai qu'on a ces images terribles c'est
malheureux c'est qu'ils partent avec une
valise blessés noir c'est sans pognon
parce que ce qu'on du pognon il ya
longtemps qu'il l'envoyait
ça c'est vraiment ça m'a fait mal au
coeur quand terry là c'était terrible
surtout avec la côte d'ivoire qui était
un modèle en plus de plusieurs peuples
qui arrivait à vivre ensemble non mais
c'est sympa ça je suis sûr qu'ils vont
revenir
j'espère bien dieu vous entende est ce
que les américains mettent de l'huile
sur le feu soit je peux pas vous dire ça
je suis pas très on a vu des
manifestants à abidjan mais vous savez
quand aux américains vous savez quand au
nez quand on est
coléreuse du canton perd 4 5 6 personnes
de sa famille me on se dit il ya quelque
chose qui va pas contre ce médiateur qui
captait un parti pris ou pas aussi bas
on est c'est dans l'état où ils sont
tout peut arriver quoi mais alors vous
avez donc interpellé le président
jacques chirac vous avez demandé une
entrevue avec lui
est-ce qui vous l'a accordé jusqu'à
aujourd'hui mais vous savez j'ai de la
chance d'avoir des marseillais dans le
gouvernement à sa sauce toujours et et
des gens comme muselier c2c passerez par
par l'ami parce que bon je le connais
très bien et renaud muselier voilà
quelques ministères les affaires
étrangères avec dominique de villepin
voilà vous voulez rencontrer jacques
chirac pour lui dire que jusque jeu de
foot regarder votre caméra parler lui
oui mais dit-il ce qu'ils regardent
l'émission en buvant sa bière tous les
samedis c'est assez tôt jacques
non mais sérieux dites lui que vous
allez me dire il la regarde les
messieurs je pense que je les esprits
mais tout à l'heure en disant que
j'aurais bien aimé que la france n'est
pas une certaine lassitude vis-à-vis du
problème ivoirien qu'elle n'a pas
considéré le poulain va rien d'entrée
comme il le fallait et sa traîner les
choses
on a besoin de la france on est très
liée à la france et que on aimerait que
les problèmes en côte d'ivoire se se
règle vraiment dans dans une une paix qu
enfin dominique de villepin a voulu en
voulaient d'avoir organisé cette réunion
de marcoussis d'avoir imposé au
président ivoirien
l'entrée de ministres rebelles dans son
gouvernement je n'en veux pas du tout
mais il a eu un portefeuille difficile
et c'était l'entrée du gouvernement
pendant que je veux dire que le
peut-être qu'ils l'étaient pas ils
n'étaient pas afro
vraiment dans le dans son arme et je les
ai vus en train de parler quand il était
quand il était interpellé par les
manifestantes devant l'imposant du
président aulas on sent que c'est
quelqu'un qui connaît pas l'afrique si
c'est injuste là où quelqu'un
qui connaît bien l'afrique il se paie et
ils attendent pas là de quoi c'est à
dire qu'il ya toujours quelque chose
avant donc on prend vraiment son calme
et là tout de suite j'ai vu quelqu'un
qu'il ne connaissait pas l'afrique
guider les hommes politiques ivoiriens
dans le problème est un problème très
important pour la france parce que la
côte d'ivoire est importante pour la
france
ça m'a semblé un peu léger vous savez
basile boli le canard enchaîné a annoncé
mercredi dernier que dominique de
villepin
suite au fiasco ivoirien avait proposé
sa démission au président jacques chirac
il l'a refusée est-ce que vous pensez
que chirac aurait dû l'accepter je suis
blanche ou pas dire je veux pas dire
parce que je pense que il est plus
habile que est la plus habile points
politiques de juger ça moi je peux pas
le juger très bien l'a compris
tu vois qui peut être blanche mans
sérieux l'asile un canton c'est grave
un sa politique non politiquement
sérieuses et pas un politique c'est
raison de la côte d'ivoire non c'est
pathétique cessé d'être interdite on est
très très attentif à temps comment il
était à l'époque du ballon la vecquée
carré il les a toujours d'ailleurs
mais c'était un sacré compétiteur ouais
c'était on pouvait compter sur lui sur
le terrain
un jour il arraché la tête d'un anglais
c'était en suède il a fallu arracher
leur dette chaque sens non parce que lui
même tempérament que luis 1 et lucien 2
la banlieue ou qui comme moi aussi et on
n'aime pas perdre et on et j'apprécie
beaucoup luis on a été souvent ensemble
dans les sélections et on a toujours été
très proches dans ce qu'il fait et
j'aime bien quand je suis un homme a
challenge lui c'est un homme a changé
comme comme didier deschamps au début je
suis pas que je protège mes les amis
mais je vois de loin les les
journalistes avec leurs fusils et en dix
ans et je sais à 10 ans et qui pourront
pas et non pas ils n'ont pas
l'expérience et ses terres ya un bon
mois j'étais furieux quand je vois que
les gens parlaient de deux décharges ne
peut pas être entraîneur et ses chars
projet aujourd'hui les mais il attaque
luis parce que ayachi en décembre à la
suisse il a gagné la coupe d'europe mais
je le suis bien sûr voilà toi comme toi
et là et moi je suis sur un petit
parisien
je suis un petit parisien il le seul
bruit c'est vrai pourquoi basile vous
êtes de romainville pourquoi vous avez
jamais joué au psg parce qu'ils vont
virer quand je voulais être ramasseur de
balles quand louise jouer
et je voulais faire un stage on a des
casses toi hein c'est ça l'histoire
l'histoire c'est que paris il regarde
pas il y à paris et sa banlieue ainsi
s'en occupe pas guy roussel occupait
allait chez guy roux d'abord avant
d'aller à marseille
là c'est laid c'est classe biberon et
puis après et après il marque le but
fabuleux en finale de la coupe d'europe
la basse balcon quand j'ai plus que
j'avais raconté qu'il avait un côté
comme d'habitude qu'aubry j'accueille
maintenant mélanie doutey mesdames
messieurs
[Musique]
bonsoir tout le monde personne alors
basile boli chanter grand footballeur
mais qui est ici pour nous parler de son
pays la côte d'ivoire
eugène saccomano on refait le match ce
soir
voilà laurent baffie c'est ce qu'a
mulder la soeur de karen qui va publier
un livre
et luis fernandez le célèbre entraîneur
du psg alors mélanie doutey tout le
monde parle de vous pour trois raisons
la première c'est le film la deuxième
c'est la pièce est la troisième en tout
cas j'espère c'est le césar la
nomination alors le film c'est la fleur
du mal le nouveau film de claude chabrol
avec nathalie baye benoît magimel
suzanne flon bernard le coq et thomas
chabrol le thème c'est la culpabilité
est elle une maladie héréditaire on
pourrait résumer ça comme ça à la fin de
la deuxième guerre mondiale au moment de
l'épuration une femme est acquitté pour
crimes et quelques décennies plus tard
de nos jours l'histoire se répète et la
morale de l'histoire c'est le temps
passe t-il où est-il un présent
perpétuel voilà c'est le thème général
alors après évidemment comme chabrol il
ya beaucoup d' intrigue qui se passe
dans la bourgeoisie mais ça c'est le le
concept général alors dans le film c'est
par vous que ce incarne cette répétition
de l'histoire familiale d'être un petit
peu rattrapé par le destin par le poids
de mes ancêtres
6 am flux en fait qui va me transmettre
un cri muet un poids de la culpabilité
et je vais porter ça ou supporter ça
comment aller voir le film
magna d'auxerre je pense que tu as
retenu tous
pendant si longtemps le temps n'existe
pas qu on verra c'est un présent
perpétuel ce que je vais te dire
personne ne le sait et personne ne le
sera jamais elle est bien bonne la
charpin vasseur remet ça malheur à nous
elle ya pris goût
depuis que les charpin et des vasseur se
marient entre eux ils sont capables de
tout séoul ou dégénéré puis ils sont
pauvres petits chiens sont cons et
michaux faut que vous compreniez quelque
chose mathieu nous sommes une famille là
justement monsieur s'agit d'une attaque
contre votre famille mais dimanche il va
falloir venir voter j'ai besoin de vous
se débrouille pas mal aux devis legault
la bo du trac stimulation avenir passe
quelque chose par la tête
c'est mon père qui l'a créé
un jour je crois bien avoir entendu
maman veut dire qu'il n'était pas mon
père mais si ça se trouve on n'aime pas
cousin
si ça se trouve juste un garçon et une
fille qui s'entendent bien qu'ils sont
bien en soi il s'est même chez les ratés
sur bien sûr qu'ils s'aimaient
mais moi je savais que toi tu es mon
mari
j'aime autant vous prévenir tout de
suite
j'étais que ma gorge à vous offrir enfin
je sais pourquoi tu es parti
un monde
tu es parti parce que tu avais peur de
ce que tu pouvais faire
[Musique]
certaines toujours les vasseur et sommes
toujours là sharp nous sommes une des
lignes voilà la fleur du mal nouveau
film de claude chabrol sorti le 19
février mais à messieurs alors il est
aussi suzanne flon sur ce tournage ça
doit être très exceptionnel abois depuis
et depuis des années vous disiez quoi je
suis jugé que les fleurs du mal c'était
baudelaire et la soeur du mali la fleur
du mal c'est chabrol voilà et je disais
que j'aime beaucoup cette une actrice
formidable
et puis qui garde encore et encore une
gamine elle elle continue à jouer à
découvrir son texte le plaisir de v puis
elle s'était jamais et s'était encore
jamais rencontrés avec chabrol donc
c'était une très belle rencontre
transmet des choses dans ces cas là
quand vous passez du temps ensemble
entre deux scènes vont démarrer
celui là une telle carrière elle a
rencontré quand même des plus grands et
du cinéma et du théâtre
on ne peut qu être enrichi par une terre
en cran alors on vous a découverte
mélanie dans le film de pierre jolivet
le frère du guerrier vous étiez l'épousé
obstiné de guillaume canet et pour ce
film vous êtes donc nommé aux césars
dans la catégorie meilleur espoir
féminin
réponse le 22 février voilà alors vous
dis merde c'est tout ce qu'on peut vous
c'est gentil voilà on vous encourage
enfin comme vous êtes fille d'acteurs
finalement vous êtes habitué à tout ça
non aux habitués et non je veux
m'habituer sinon je m'en vais très très
vite moi non mais je suis très contente
j'ai un j'ai une chance énorme quand
même tout ce qui m'arrive à 24 pages
c'est pas mal donc
alors il ya le film il ya le césar
j'espère et puis au théâtre du palais
royal il ya l'éventail de lady
windermere donc la première comédie
écrite pas oscar wilde
[Musique]
avec caroline cellier oui hein donc
c'est quoi l'histoire l'histoire c'est
une jeune femme le jour de son
anniversaire de ses 21 ans elle va se
rendre compte que la vie n'est pas si
simple que ça pour résumer très
simplement que ça non mais c'est elle a
été élevée d'une certaine manière les
gens étaient gentils les gens étaient
méchants
puis c'est un tout petit peu plus
complexe et il va y avoir un rapport
assez mystérieux avec caroline cellier
qui est-elle pourquoi elle veut rentrer
dans sa vie fait très bien la promo 1 je
trouve assez vrai ah ça c'est une
qualité un des actrices qui viennent ici
ils sont incapables de vendre leur truc
fait ça très bien pour rappel de l'autre
konecranes je pense que maintenant vous
allez vous reposer un petit peu
voilà maintenant plus que vous arrivez
du théâtre donc reposez vous si laurent
baffie qui va terminer cette interview à
votre place le lot d'accord vous la
voyez comment mais l'ami votre carrière
maintenant que du bon que des bronches à
24 ans l'avenir une bande moi penser que
le césar pourrait changer beaucoup de
choses mais l'ami
non non je pense que ma carrière est
tracé je suis une bonne comédienne aime
et il a marqué et le césar c'est ça la
cerise sur le gâteau ouais enfin ça
c'est suffisant ou pas césar j'encule de
ses armes dans sa carrière il y aura
avancé tim story léo et après être
actrice
oui vous m'écoutez un peu ma petite
mélanie oui je vous écoute je vous
écoute je veux tellement mignonne je
remercie voudriez tournée avec qui avec
tous les grands oui par exemple bas
chabrol s'est fait avec avec blier avec
billet bien sûr avec jean jacques annaud
évidemment voilà la suite de l'ours
et puis avec tous les tous ceux qui me
désire vous savez être femme c'est
sentir le le désirent dans le regard du
metteur marc dorcel non non écouter on
vit déjà ensemble je crois
ah bon mais l'ami ces crimes et délits
vous vous avez un teint magnifique vous
en prenez soin comment écoutez moi je
demande simplement des produits de
beauté simple jeu c'est de l'huile
d'olive et du lait d'ânesse voilà huit
fois par jour ça paie un poste régnant
sur les tournages mais c'est efficace
il vous je veux vous faites quoi pour
mes cheveux par spéciale non non ils
sont vachement bien le cheveu la wii
alors j'ai un secret oui mais je n'ai
pas le droit de le révéler
car il m'a été livré par madame de
fontenay en personne en personne et le
secret est sous scellé sous son chapeau
et je n'ai pas le droit de révéler que
vous trouvez pas un peu pénible à
mélanie qu'on laisse jamais les jeunes
actrices s'exprimer à la télévision oui
et je vous remercie de me donner
un micro une tribune ouverte car c'est
vrai que les jeunes actrices sont
relégués au rôle de potiche et ça fait
du bien de pouvoir s'exprimer clairement
sur les sujets de fond mercy tirez vous
trouvez comment laurent baffie assez
sympa assez sympa je suis sûr qu'ils
aient un petit coeur qui bossent tous
avant je le trouve assez sexy et
j'aimerais bien avoir une aventure avec
les attend
on
[Musique]
bon
et maintenant
[Musique]
si doc gynéco
dallas
[Musique]
doucement doucement bon papa qui amuse
linge ce serait qu'une petite tendinite
comme ça en s'asseyant ses combats avec
l'arrivée de trois rues c'est vrai alors
doc gynéco bonsoir vous êtes nommé vous
évidemment non pas aux césars mais aux
victoires dans la catégorie meilleur
album rap hip hop de l'année
l'album s'appelle solitaire
[Musique]
le single s'appelle frotti frotta
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
aux mondiaux exigent le cube magnéto
serge
[Musique]
allons
en soi
du vieux pain met du piment dans mon cas
sont des de l'argot des beaux mots et du
créole dans tous mes couplets doc gynéco
duo d'ex tony bedi possible retard
extrait le camp dernier cd soul eater
voilà alors donc vous votre mère est
guadeloupéen lui stomie son père et cap
verdien et vous avez décidé donc d'aller
faire une tournée chez vous et de faire
un titre là bas un nom en fait j'ai pas
été à la tournée allait d'ailleurs n'est
pas venu ce tome est passé jusqu'à
présent ils sont fâchés contre moi j'ai
préféré me concentrer sur des textes
l'avion qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est
pareil je vais arriver pas te réveiller
toile avait prévu un truc de barbe à
rien on
louer des les plus grandes salles des
antilles et on voulait y aller avec
juste une des athées une cassette jeu
reprenait la tête pour qu'ils aient
toute la lumière etc
on sait pas entendu on attend je veux
dire que tu es fâché que ce tome i
jamais de la vie un banc avec qui tu
t'es pas entendu l'ingénieur de un
luminaire hattori à dakar est donc en
fait t'es pas aller faire la tournée qua
non à quoi tu as dormi tafer drogue
souci aussi des d'impôt est pas besoin
de thunes oui on peut mais non ça ne
regarde ta caméra regarde la caméra il
dit demande de l'argent mais j'en vends
ton n'en voyez vous avez besoin d'argent
j'en ai beaucoup
on va écouter ce qui fait quand tu
travailles didier
pourquoi tu fais ça pour s'en sortir
[Musique]
ça
des abris la loi
[Musique]
c'est
dix concerts
je
[Musique]
bilan deux mois dit sur quoi on dit sur
toi le président
de toi
[Musique]
sentant réside pas son fort
tu
quand même
mon père est né là bas moi je suis
mombert
moi je suis né
j'ai quand même
aussi
je veux
[Musique]
aussi
je veux
je vous aime jambes et l'avis de
sinon je t'emmène schéma
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant
punk rap équitable
sa terrasse mais dès qu'ils voient
qui brille
[Musique]
me sur ta cherche des
des gens dans des cases
[Musique]
le romantique quel bord de mer
bien chez moi à boire un dernier verre
tout cas je veux
la vie de rue
aucune rente jeu dans mes classes
[Musique]
j'attends
m
et c'est parfois ton
[Musique]
mexico non
doc gynéco m'en voudrez pas de part
hormis votre duo avec un tapis parce que
franchement super top fan de ça mais
c'est vrai que je trouve que là vous
avez retrouvé avec ce cd la solitaire la
veine de votre premier album doc
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pourquoi d'un
seul coup ça redevient bien là oui c'est
mieux
c'est bien non elle vraiment non c'est
mieux alors parce que j'ai pu j'ai voulu
explorer faire des morceaux avec renault
nanar et c'est faire un petit peu de
basket ball avait mis mes pairs les
harlem globe trotters
après je me suis dit quand même que je
fasse plaisir aux mecs du quartier
toujours me demander quand est ce que
tous nous refaire son classique de balle
zen
donc je me suis mis j'ai commencé à rots
j'ai pas envie de refaire à chaque fois
la même chose ça me dérange c'est pas
pour avancer c'est pour explorer la je
suis aux frontières du réel
il fallut attendre
ça lui prend du temps je vois c'est pas
les mecs qui mettent un an pour faire un
album mais mais qui met deux ans pis
voilà c'est comme l'aîné les jongles où
les dribbles de 2 comment s'appellent
ces joueurs brésiliens super fort
ronaldinho c'est aussi celui de
montferrand retourne rsa a vite fait des
fois ils essayent de faire des trucs
plus compliqué des têtes dépassent il
arrive pas alors à helmand foot j'ai pas
mal arrivé bon sur le côté droit est pas
mal mais joue à quelques temps c'est une
façon d'accélérer
non
alors vous avez déclaré au mois de
novembre que vous étiez en train
d'écrire un film de cinéma
doc gynéco a intitulé le plus vieux
métier du monde sans nez ou leur garage
j'ai rencontré des producteurs de films
qui m'ont dit que c'était trop pointu
alors quand le mec qui m'a dit ça j'ai
dit j'ai un court métrage
c'est l'histoire d'un mec qui se
réveille le matin avec la gaule et qui
ne manque pas de toupet celle ci voulait
faire un film soit plus vieux métier du
monde
il faut vous dépêcher parce que avec
sarkozy bientôt des films qui aurait put
ça sera jurassic park je le mets au défi
et demain il n'y ait plus un bout de
shit dans les rues à une prostituée un
clandestin
ça vous choque j'avais déclaré j'y crois
pas quand tu es ministre de l'intérieur
tant mieux à faire que d'inventer des
flashball et que d'aller courir après
trois pauvres gitans et une douzaine de
prostituées ben oui surtout que ça fait
maintenant partie de notre culture
bah oui ça m'inspire s'il y avait plus
ces gens là je peux plus travailler
vous êtes un spécialiste parce que dans
votre jeunesse avait beaucoup étudié la
la prostitution dans le quartier de la
chapelle c'est quelque chose qui vous a
beaucoup occupés ça oui ça m'a touché
profondément pour certaines
c'est là que vous êtes devenu polygame
c'est à ce moment là oui je pense que
mon père m'a aidé vous saviez mélanique
avant de s'appeler doc gynéco bruno
beausir s'appelait langue de velours
cela laisse rêveur
oui et oui tu fais le vent vieux cela
bien le rêve des trucs gynéco est temps
de partir son île déserte
on va faire une interview île déserte
alors donc si vous étiez sur une île
déserte vous préféreriez être robinson
crusoé ou vendredi on aurait dit vous
choisiriez qui comme robinson sont
j'hésite entre michelle pfeiffer anne
sinclair
si vous étiez sur une île déserte au
bout de combien de temps auriez vous
envie de faire l'amour avec des animaux
pense tout de suite s'ils étaient seuls
oui est ce que est ce que tu contrer les
jours les étoiles plus tôt 1 est ce que
tu ferais macérer des fruits pour faire
de l'alcool forcément qui serait ton
copain imaginaire
[Musique]
jacques chirac
est-ce que tu fonderait une nouvelle
nation sur cette île oui ça serait
comment cette nouvelle nation fait de
jolie métisse et des jolis mulâtre
eurasienne et eurasien est-ce que tu
faudrait une nouvelle religion sur cette
île oui de nanak et 1
c'est quoi c'est un hacker ici c'est
très compliqué est ce que si tu étais
sur une île déserte eut fait signe au
bateau pour leur dire de dégager
oui forcément et si tu voyais le
chanteur antoine débarquer sur cette île
qu'est ce que tu fais non non parce
qu'antoine aime trop la musique c'est
fou comme délai la meilleure sonne bien
[Musique]
et maintenant un frigidaire un joli
scooter anatomique se réduit dans
l'opinion une cuisinière avec un
français d'être à découvert mais les
pelle à gâteau
j'accueille philippe starck
bonsoir
saint amand soir vous connaissez tous le
monde presque mélanie doutey j'avais
remarqué déjà c'est-à-dire en cabine de
maquillage de chabrol et la palais royal
avec caroline cellier
voilà je vais prendre plus tôt ce modèle
là alors on s'est rencontré il ya
longtemps philippe ya 25 ans la première
fois dans les bureaux d'un journal
brancher des halles qui s'appelait
façade en compagnie de jean baptiste
mondino
et ce jour là vous avez expliqué que les
gens au xxème siècle habitait toujours
dans des grottes et ça m'a complètement
scotché parce que c'est vrai ça continue
voilà même au 21ème siècle voilà même
21e le problème en plus c'est qu'ils
s'endettent à vie pour se voiler des
grottes way pour celui des crottes un
problème et dont les années suivantes
quand on se rencontrer dans des boîtes
de nuit
vous me racontiez que vous faisiez des
choses à dallas à tokyo à ryad
et moi je me disais le mec complètement
mito quoi possible et c'était vrai plus
oui je t'ai vu tout aussi 1 1 peut faire
les deux oui on peut faire un peu mytho
est aujourd'hui 25 ans après vous êtes
devenu philippe une une star mondiale
dont il est plus facile de dire ce
qu'elle a pas fait que ce qu'elle a fait
ouais les boîtes de nuit les cafés des
hôtels des immeubles des brosses à dents
des bronchioles des [ __ ] pour les
mouches hathaway toutou que n'avez vous
pas dessiner ce que je n'ai pas dessiner
c'est tout ce que je n'aimerais pas
dessiner en fait parce que plein de
choses d'abord pars du principe qu'on ne
s'est pas forcé de dessiner on n'est pas
forcé de produire
l'importance est donnée de donner plus
tôt le résultat aux gens si un jour tu
arrives et tu me dis j'ai froid au lieu
de vendre un radiateur sera plutôt mieux
que je te prennes dans mes bras
la vraie réponse aujourd'hui c'est ça
essayer de rendre le service que la
personne demande sans passer par toute
la merde au tour alors philippe boulet
tenir chi tech ni décorateur ni
designers vous êtes un touche à tout de
génie non j'essaie seulement d'être un
citoyen responsable
c'est déjà un full time job ouais c'est
déjà pas mal et touche-à-tout oui
touche à tout alors c'est un thé à vic
parce que votre père andré store qui
était industrielle dans l'aéronautique
inventeur une sorte de géo trouvetou
déjà je trouve tooway est là pour les
chi c'est même lui qui a inventé le
rouge à lèvres hélicoïdal rouge à lèvres
comme ça un bon maire qu'est ce que vous
feriez les filles sans mon père un homme
sans moi je vous dis ça mais art
il dessinait des avions il décidé qu'à
inventer aussi l'ailé revêtement
antidérapant pour les bateaux
cette sorte de d'enzo ferrari de l'air
ouais alors il se levait très tard il
vivait dans une pièce minuscule il se
levait très tard il avait toujours trois
dames dans son lit
vers 3 heures il faisait le marché vers
5 heures ils se mettaient à déjeuner
avec ses potes une vie formidable
moi j'ai fait strictement le contraire
j'ai gardé une femme dans mon lit
presque toute ma vie et je me lève tôt
pour travailler et j'ai même plus le
temps de déjeuner ont déjà conquis
beaucoup plus riche que lui c'est
possible alors pourquoi avoir cessé de
lui parler pendant pendant dix ans j'ai
trouvé qu'il n'était pas correct avec ma
mère après le son divorce
j'ai décidé de ne pas lui parler qui
doit être à mon avis quelque chose
d'assez terrible mais je pense que la
punition était bien trop terrible et
donc vous viviez votre mère comme ça
dans ses errances de deux grands
appartements vente d'appartement en
appartement vide dans votre appartement
vide est arrivé dans la poussière
une enfance assez étrange un peu
schizophrène alors totalement
schizophrène alors vous aviez étant
petit le un sentiment d'exclusion
vous sentiez pas de ce monde et vous
viviez comme l'homme invisible et vous
avez dit quelque chose de très beau
c'est qu'en fait comme l'homme invisible
a besoin de bandelettes pour être vu
vous avez fait toute cette production en
fait pour être vu pour cesser d'être
invisible par des hasards par des
hasards on sait pas pourquoi j'avais
développé un angle de vue un langage un
petit peu différent autrement de
différence globale et de la société des
enfants des adolescents n'aime pas la
différence est donc plus qu'être rejetée
qui pourra une réaction
on n'est finalement pas vu et à l'époque
on aimerait bien connaître quelques
filles et avoir des copains des copines
des trucs comme ça quand on voit encore
on d'une pièce et qu'on voit les filles
vous travers du regard comme s'ils
n'existaient pas et à ce moment là on se
referme commence à chambry bordel qu'est
ce que je vais faire
déjà que je comprends rien à l'école que
je comprends rien à la société
il va falloir trouver un moyen et à ce
moment là on se rappelle du film de
l'homme invisible et on se rappelle
aussi du sapin de noël à ses fans elle
s'appelle comme tout le monde mais le
jour on lui met des boules de noël bat
on remarque le sapin milly la forêt
c'est ce que j'ai fait donc je suis un
énorme sapin de noël maintenant mais si
vous n'aviez pas eu cette enfance un peu
malheureuse vous auriez peut-être rien
d'étrange envahir étrange vous n'aurez
rien fait votre vie
sûrement sûrement je veux pas dire que
le malheur où l'étrangeté soit une
obligation à la création même
ça aide mais on le paye toute sa vie
c'est le mythe c'est le mythe de faust
c'est mythe de faust ou fausse temps on
vend son âme au diable pour être plus
jeune pour être plus riches
moi j'ai vendu ma vie à la création
c'est à dire ça fait 30 ans que j'ai pas
eu une minute peut ouvrir rouge crous
courant cultiver mon magma maintenant
vous existez en même temps ouais et je
pourrais même exister sans la création
maher donc maintenant philippe vous
existez effectivement vous êtes marié
avec une jeune américaine très jolie
dont vous n'êtes plus invisible c'est
vous qui l'avez dessinée non non ça
aurait été trop difficile elle est
vraiment trop impeccable les lignes sont
tendues ces sublimes
ça c'est la première bonne nouvelle donc
à la deuxième c'est que l'excellent
éditeur tâche n republie un ouvrage
consacré à vos oeuvres
[Musique]
et la troisième bonne nouvelle c'est
donc beaubourg le centre pompidou qui
vous consacre du 26 février au 12 mai
une exposition dont la scénographie a
été conçu par vous
[Musique]
ça doit faire un drôle d'effet quand
même d'avoir beaubourg qui vous est
consacré georges beaubourg
j'ai reculé j'ai jeté tout fait pour pas
la faire et finalement je me suis dit
quitte à la faire autant la faire de mon
vivant
et ça sent le sapin ouais mais je me
suis finalement sa part il n'y a pas de
raison que je sois da soit en amuser
montmusée chez à la salle de bain des
gens les chiottes des gens les choses
comme ça je me suis dit je trouve une
façon que ça serve à autre saut je vais
le faire et finalement j'ai fait une
exposition où on ne montre rien acquis
entièrement vie ça c'est nouveau
simplement je me fout à poil dedans et
où je dis aux gens regardez au lieu dans
une société où tout en verre
l'admiration de l'autre afin que vous
deveniez rien une bouche tube digestif
un consommateur a target consumers un
spectateur je vais faire une machine à
vous réveiller a dit regardez le gros
con là qui vous parle et il a dessiné
tout ça il a passé sa vie à faire ça eh
bien vous pourriez faire la même chose
mais qu'il devait analyser le décor ici
vous diriez quoi
eh bien depuis le début je me demande
c'est un mixte assez étonnant que j'ai
du mal à la et un côté pompéien j'aime
ceux là je suis incapable de dire
quelque chose mais c'est très bien je ne
critique pas le capiton je voulais piqué
non mais vous savez que un bon décor ses
décors qu'on ne peut pas identifier
si je dis ces néo classique mais il faut
bien là dans ce cas là c'est fait ce
qu'il faut toujours s'est brouillé les
signes afin que le mental marche c'est
un jeu mental de trouver pourquoi du
orange psychédélique comme ça au petit
kart vasarely des années 70 avec du
néoclassique de choses comme ça pourquoi
c'est ça et on commence à travailler
avec elle ça va faire un gros levier
fait d'être exposé à beaubourg de son
vivant non non pas ça c'est pas de moi
qu'on expose
et n'importe qui qu'on a pris dans la
rue sauf qu'on l'a pris plus traçable
qu'un autre tous les cas ça mérite un
triomphe romain
m
certains messieurs j'adore on peut le
refaire à j'adore
voilà donc à beaubourg très bientôt
alors j'ai les territoires très beau
bourg
quand on a eu beau bout qu'est-ce qu'on
peut avoir de mieux après le ghana on
meurt de vieillesse
ah oui c'est ça c'est ce que je compte
faire vous avez une maladie qui est très
agréable pour ceux qui vous entourent
philippe starck vous avez le syndrome du
clown ouais au syndrome du clown c'est
une maladie qui est peu reconnu par la
part des sociétés ont fait certains
chartistes
et voilà on critique le clown ont fait
dit vous sans penser que c'est lui qui
se met en quatre pour combler les
silences d'une conversation sinon nous
renvoie là où cacher une situation
délicate
c'est vrai que la bourre l'âme fait
l'artiste invité à tout le monde
embarque dans la vie quotidienne vous
avez ce syndrome du clown j'ai eu le
malheur de recevoir une bonne éducation
et l'idée qu'il puisse y avoir un moment
un silence un malaise
quelqu'un qui puisse être mal à l'aise
bas un moment s'il ya le crétin qui va
jeter à l'eau il va se rouler dans le
pipi pour faire et tout le monde est bas
j'irai et là après il ya les gens qui
lisent mais gentiment fin complètement
mais qui faisait alors que tant lui
bonjour il laisse pas parler les autres
savent c'était pour faire plaisir à son
habitude très charitable en fait attend
tellement oui totalement
comment ça se passe avec mélanie doc
je trouvais très en tout cas je passe ma
vie sur ta veste et y voilà oui ça ça me
flatte sûr ah oui facile là maintenant
donc on passe maintenant blind test ce
soir un blind test spécial pop music
j'appelle platine masyaf héliporté
[Musique]
bonjour est avec nous j'appelle martinez
que aulas
et
là
[Musique]
alors martin et que on vous a connu chez
christine bravo à vous étiez là à la
hollandaise vos amis c'est ce qu'a
mulder et qui aussi les bataves comme
vous et vous venez de finir l'écriture
de votre album et vous cherchez une
maison de disque 1
c'est quoi comme style de chanson c'est
pas obsédé cros et trip hop c'est la
jazz c'est en anglais c'est la partie
facile tu vois vraiment éclectique mon
univers moment vous souhaite bien du
courage c'est de trouver
arnaud gidoin bonsoir shakespeare le
défi donc au palais des glaces ça marche
toujours bien c'est génial il m'a retiré
samedi 30 c est pascal cm donc est en
tournée avec notre ami baffie bien alors
on passe au blind test vous connaissez
la règle du jeu
dans un premier temps c'est par équipes
donc l équipe de mélanie doutey contre
l'équipe de sesca mulder et à partir
d'un certain moment vous le savez bien
vous c'est chacun pour sa gueule
1 vous le savez bien alors didier
[Musique]
ah ça va commencer attention fils
je n'y sois flash je veux dire un truc
je peux dire un truc hyper qu'ils font
c'est de dire gainsbourg avant laurent
parce que je me sens sur et je n'ose pas
dire
m
plus ou si tu marques un point à
préciser que c'est la troisième fois
qu'elle me fait le coup c'est pas la
première je sais attention
non c'est qui partout c'est parti wesh
fidèles
buté a partout c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué maintenant attention fille
l'histoire est originale danilo plein
temps
[Musique]
narry d'un fourré je le crois pas je ne
crois pas le mandat fait j'ai vécu
quatre ans avec esprit avant mais ça
comment il peut reconnaître marie
laforêt dans paint it black des jeux
veut bien l'entendre chanter
ouais on va leur mail valeur m
[Musique]
marie laforêt dans paint it black on
continue philippe
[Musique]
car j'ai l'impression qu'on m'a dit bon
score psg là à sa meilleur salaire
un score marseille psg peut voir ça en
replay mais pascal sellem m'a traité de
fils de [ __ ]
alors qu'il connaît très bien ma maman
thierry plet ses amis plus
[Musique]
je
au début tu veux tester sur poids de ma
mère je m'excuse alors non je vous prie
de m'excuser tu voudrais m'excuser maman
marion d'achever le maman maman
attention
[Musique]
version originale la version originale
celle acquise par le groupe qui chante
et de la glisse blacks ils sont morts
c'est l'espagnol justement non légaux
nationaux
attention attention fini
ça
[Musique]
laurent batîment ça
non comment alors là je crois partagée
une oreillette c'est une chanson qui
s'appelle elvira yade qui a été reprise
par claude françois personnes le code ci
lui comment tu fais je tiens ta femme
elle m'a dit c'est la seule explication
j'ai une sectoriellement traitée de
beaucoup de noms mais changer lui c'est
pas du tout d'accord attention fille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux points pour l'équipe de mélanie
doutey
[Musique]
4 pour l'équipe de sesca mulder trois
ans l'équipe de mélanie doutey attention
film
[Musique]
non
e
[Musique]
sauvage
là
[Musique]
je
pardon grâce à toi l'équipe remonte
c'est inné c'est d'aller fière chandelle
mélanie doutey un bon coach aussi votre
meilleur c'était très très dur
elle apparaît maintenant c'est chacun
pour sa gueule là il ya plus d'équipés
ya plus personne
si vous faites attention
me
c'est vous
je ne
c
neymar
eh oui
méline alors qu'est ce que c'est que ce
boulot pour la wii c'est le banco bien
sûr le vent qu a été gagné par philippe
starck bien entendu voilà que l'on sort
gagnant du bon commandant
mais après le bon coup il ya le super
banco
ainsi pourquoi c'est dégueulasse
[Musique]
aïe
oh
kdc martiniquais ou ses bases il l'a dit
tous les deux mais ce soir on est
[Musique]
jaurès attention philippe même à cette
impasse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
repris en france et par franck alamo
exact les turtles happy together non
plus cette chanson adamo chante plus
franck alamo attention balance et
l'ultra bon coup on est bien d'accord
celui ou celle qui va remporter l'ultra
banco sera le grand gagnant je suis ou
la grande gagnante en premier la hill et
keirrison ne trouve l'ultra banco c'est
le gagnant du méga banco laurent baffie
qui sera le gagnant de la soirée
bruno gagné repartirez avec elle que son
traîneau gangan barbara brock est
d'accord et la moche
très attention
le mois de jeûne méline mais tu peux
avoir aussi médicaux mais attention
attention là on y est à celle ultra bon
coup là c'est maintenant cestas
introuvable
non
à
jean-claude vendre
thomas
à
oh
m
les en mai
on sait pas que quelqu'un trouve la
caisse
moi
à
mais voilà c'était tout l'enjeu
l'émission qui ne dort pas du tout
avec l'arabe la langue
elisabeth teissier
tels ont retrouvé sous des semaines
d'antenne
omar haddad
bonchamp livre pourquoi moi publié aux
éditions du seuil
oui c'est un modèle
jouer
eugène saccomano aux flammes at jeu
prolongation
merci beaucoup et
l'ange externe
c'est la vraie vie
de l'arno
albin michel
je scanne le vernir sûr
une superwoman appris à voler
protection des sols
[Musique]
mélanie doutey
de lady windermere
le faire du palais royal
et la fleur du mal de paul chabrol avec
nathalie
benoît magimel ça sort le 10
gecko sont en europe
mais solitaire et le single
sa peine
gotti quotas c'est l'amour qui contrôle
avec jolivet qui il est
handisport
briller sur france 2
ça
[Musique]
exposition de boulot
10 février au 10 mai
christian nouvelle édition chez cash est
la nouvelle émission et europe à partir
de mars 2003 reporter sans frontières
dignity alléchant ligne aura bien deux
chine mais maintenant tu as apporté
marié sait pas
absolument l'avoir souhaité tirer le
blocage de ce soir c'est chez universal
je vous donne rendez-vous dans quinze
jours la semaine prochaine dans quinze
jours la grèce les prochaines
ce sens les
merci la rue
je ne
là
[Musique]
nous avons
un jeu
je ne
[Musique]
comment
m
[Musique]
art
damas